want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe
life and get some incredible motivation
from the one and only
lisa nichols enjoy
i was hungry like i was hungry people
often
want to call me the exception like oh my
god you're the exception
no i'm not the exception i'm an average
ordinary woman who chose every day to
make one more extraordinary decision
i'm an average ordinary mom who said i
want to drastically transform my son's
future
that he deserves to have every option
that every other child would have
irregardless of what he was born into i
just was crazy enough
to believe that that it doesn't matter
the color of my skin
doesn't matter my religious background
doesn't matter my origin
it doesn't matter my mom's bank account
my dad's been kind when i was born none
of that
means my future that's just the
circumstance that i came from that's not
what defines my future i just believed
that not a lot validated it
but faith is believing in the unseen
anyway
so i had enough faith to go i know like
i know like i know like i know
i don't necessarily have to see it yet
christy talked about affirmations
abundant thinkers understand the power
of i am
anything after the word i am is true to
your unconscious mind michael
anything anything after i am anything
anything
after i am even if you just you know
it's not true your conscious mind will
believe it
anything after i am so the use of
affirmations is very intentional
and very consistent
i was diagnosed as clinically depressed
and two thousand and
one ninety-four five and six nine seven
two
nineteen ninety eight i'm sorry i was
diagnosed as clinically depressed
me it didn't make sense i had been in a
relationship i was engaged to get
married
and my fiance um who i did not know at
the time
uh was bipolar and he stopped taking his
medicines and under the belief system
that love can cure anything and so
um i ended up being picked up and thrown
three feet across the room
and i end up being choked until i passed
out and once i got out of that
relationship
i just was different it was different so
my mom insisted that i go to the
doctor i went to the doctor and i sat on
the table
and she checked me and talked to me and
came back in with a prescription
and she said alisa you're clinically
depressed
and i felt like i heard charlie brown's
parents talking like
why want clinically depressed at least
that makes sense in that same sentence
and she handed me a prescription
and i read the prescription and had my
name on it and it said prozac
not that that'll make sense lisa nichols
that don't make sense
and i said do you mean i'm sad
she said very very sad i said can i try
something and i'm not
i'm not uh recommending you guys if
you're on medication you stop taking
your meds
please don't do that i asked my doctor
she agreed i said do you
mind if i try something before i take
this she goes yes but i need to see you
back in 30 days
if you're in the same condition i need
us to try this medicine i said okay i
can do that
so i went home and every day
i got in the mirror and i drilled i
am every day because i realized i have
forgotten
who i was yes i just forgot i just and
it was okay to forget i just forgot
so every day every day for 25 minutes i
just went over the i ams
every day i am i am i am and then i
i parallel that with i forgive you for
then i parallel that what i commit to
you lisa
every single day i went back in 30 days
and i'm talking to her and i'm on fire
she's just looking at me
and i'm just talking talking she twisted
her head again and i'm just talking
talking she says
wait i gotta stop you i said what she
goes what are you taking
and can i have some i was like i'm
taking some of me
and so the power of i am the power of i
am can pull you through the darkest
moment the power of i am
when you want to learn how to trust your
intuition more
you know i say and this is me and my
walk and my
my belief system that your intuition is
your internal
gps system your internal
god placement system it's that whisper
and sometimes it's that scream that
tells you to leap
or to be still your intuition is
a combination of spirit emotion
and logic and it's guiding you
and so often we don't hear our intuition
why don't we hear it because we're
having too much chatter
in our head like the chatter in our head
doubt
worry judgment oh my god
judgment or fear fear of other people's
perception of you
so your intuition is saying i love to
dance i want to dance i want to sing
your intuition is saying we can have a
great time your intuition said i want
love
your intuition is saying gosh let's go
take that chance on that writing that
book
or let's take that chance on starting
that business then your chatter comes in
no what if i fail so let me explain this
to you
your mind your brain is designed to keep
you safe
it's designed and it only has the
ability to go back in time
in the mental file cabinet and look at
the last time you tried something like
this
and it may not have been um good or it
may have ended in some dangerous
situations where people could judge you
and your brain is designed to protect
you
that's it your brain decides to protect
you it's logical your intuition
is that spark of passion it's that spark
of desire
it's that spark of love it's that spark
of pull me forward it's that little bit
of radical it's that
a lot of bit of um of i want to leave my
fingerprint on this planet your brain
isn't designed to have those same ideas
now
now your intuition can kick the brain in
and the brain can start thinking of ways
too but the intuition is where it's
going to start
it's in your gut it seems it's why when
you feel something you kind of go here
you don't go
oh i feel so special you don't say i
feel special here
you say i feel it here i feel it here
and so your job
is not to turn down the doubt
your job is to turn up the passion it's
to turn
up the faith it's to turn up the
possibility
now still make well-thought-out plans i
always say
the best plan is the plan made i don't
care if you have to upgrade it you have
to modify it
but if you if you if you if you
fail to plan then you've planned to fail
so every dream every passion every
desire
follow it with a plan because that's
where your brain gets excited your brain
goes yeah
we got a plan now now you can believe
yourself see
you set big goals and dreams and you
have desires and then you don't
achieve it but you don't achieve it
because you didn't set the plan in place
you didn't do the details and then you
stopped believing you could do it
and then you do the biggest tragedy you
stop
dreaming you stop hoping
you stop stretching yourself you stop
listening to your
gps your god placement system that says
you've been put here
on a divine assignment and your
assignment may
change over years guess what your
assignment you had 15 years ago may be
very different from the assignment on
your life today
your job is to turn down the volume
in your head the volume of judgment the
volume of fear
the volume of worry the volume of
perfection
turn down the volume in your head and
turn
up the volume in your intuition then
your
solar plex in that god placement system
in that heart space turn up the volume
in that place that just says
what do i want what ask yourself this
tonight today
tomorrow what feels good to my soul
and then be still and be quiet
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self-confidence i have
designed a free training program just
for you
where every day for the next 254 days
i'll send you
an email with an unlisted video to help
you boost your confidence
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
and so i want you to build the habit of
self belief and self confidence
it's 100 free the link to join is in the
description
below we validate who we are
by what we're doing for other people so
many times i get the question
how do i prevent failure and i'd love
for you
to spend that same energy going how
could i
ensure that i soar cognitive dissonance
is when you have literally thought about
a version of yourself that you're not
currently living right now to me this is
the road to true freedom
i have nothing to prove i have nothing
to protect
i have nothing to hide and i have
nothing to defend
that your perception of me after i tell
my truth
is actually none of my business my
perception of me
that i go to bed as whole and complete
as i woke up
before i check how many likes i have on
facebook that i like me first
and every other like is bonus there you
go
like it that was a long road to get to
long road
sure long road there's so much value in
what you
unlearn sometimes the best thing you can
do is unlearn some things
we're all always going after learning
something new
because we're information junkies
because we we have all these forms of
information coming at us on the internet
coming at us in books coming at us on
the radio coming at us in television
that we want to learn learn learn but
sometimes your biggest breakthrough
is in what you unlearn and then you
relearn
sometimes you have to disrupt your soil
pull your soil up
take that dry dirt that's been planted
for years i know
i just been knowing this for years this
is what my mother taught me this is what
we've always known
you have to disrupt that soil in order
to plant a new seed
to grow a new fruit yeah yeah you guys
got that
and so i came very comfortably to
disrupt your soil
like that's what i came for to disrupt
your soil not to necessarily keep you
comfortable in what you know
stay comfortable in that i want to
disrupt you in some things that are new
awareness to go oh
wait hold on or a new awareness about
what you've been doing based on what
you've known forever
that doesn't fit your future anymore
because i can guarantee you every single
one of us who want something different
than what we're getting
we're doing something unconsciously from
old patterns
that doesn't even serve our future
that's when the tongue in your mouth
and the tongue in your shoe are going in
two totally different directions
and your job is to align them up so that
you can move forward in a powerful way
every single thing you touch is impacted
by your story
as an attorney as a teacher as an
architect
there's not one line of business that
you can be in that a story
and a great story won't elevate your
outcome every
single line of business every single
line of service
that you're connected to will be
impacted and ideally
elevated by the level in which you're
willing to tell and share your story
so let me give you some guidelines some
parameters
what i like to call the bumper rails as
if you're going bowling you know when i
go bowling i ask them to put the little
bumper rails down so i can stay
my ball can get down the lane so let me
set up some bumper rails for you
so that you understand what makes a
great story
so one is the willingness to take risk
most people vision when they're telling
a story they don't want to take a risk
so the story has
it has its limits on how high it'll go
or how deep it'll go
and when you have that then you're
really not at that part that's going to
touch my soul so being willing to take a
risk
being clear and concise with your
stories
a great story is a show me story not
a tell me story now this is the
distinction that's the game changer for
most
most people are telling a story they say
um
so let me just share with you a little
bit of my story and i'll tell you and
then i'll
show you so as i was building my life
there was a time in my life that was
very difficult it was very challenging
true story
very difficult very challenging very
uncomfortable i didn't have a lot of
money
i didn't have a lot of hope and things
just looked dismal at some point i had
to turn my life around at some point
i made the decision that life had to get
better i'm telling you that
it's decent you learn about me then if i
were to show you that story
i would say six days a week
i had to eat beanies and weenies i had
to
find money in the crevices and the
corners
of my couch so that i can get my sun
milk
there were times when my heart would
beat fast just at
what am i gonna have tomorrow at some
point i got
sick and tired of my own story
is this going to be my future no i can't
handle it
notice the difference in that second
story i completely see that
i just painted a picture same story now
the second one when you show a story
it's gonna
require more of you it's gonna require
you to find the colors
what were you thinking what were you
experiencing what was going on in your
head
instead of telling me you look for money
turn and point now this is
anywhere this is anywhere you are doing
anything i promise you you become a
great storyteller
and you will captivate your audience no
matter what you're doing
i've captivated investors i've
captivated students i've captivated
educators because i was willing to
show the story i call it unpacking the
story vision
being willing to tell me what were you
thinking what were you feeling what were
you saying
think about a story as an oral movie
and so in an oral movie think when you
look at a movie the first thing they do
is they identify what state of time it
is is it futuristic
is it in the now was it back in the day
you notice that based on what people are
wearing
how they're talking so paint that
picture for me
take me to that environment set the
backdrop up for me
show me what you're going through
instead of saying i was angry
you can tell me you were angry but when
you say the hair on the back of my neck
was standing up
i felt the fumes exiting my nose i
thought that my chest was going to pop
and i was going to say something that
i'd regret forever
ooh you just showed me you were angry
take that extra time to unpack it
why will most people not do that because
it requires a level of vulnerability
that we're not willing to share
myth number two is that abundance is
singularly focused on
possessions and money right that's
what it's all about what you drive what
you live in how much money you make
when in fact this couldn't be further
from the truth
wealth is possessions and money
abundance is a 360 experience
abundance is a 3-6
experience true abundance true abundance
is your health because if you don't have
great health
life does not feel good abundance is
relationship
and at the end of your life literally
you will measure the quality of your
life
by the quality of the relationships you
had
all the other stuff will fall away that
promotion you're thinking about you're
wondering about that race
it will fall away in the area of
importance when you get to the end of
your life
you will begin to look at the quality of
your relationships how are your children
relating to you how your siblings relate
to
do you have love in your life you
literally will start looking at
relationships
at a higher level as you get older
so when you mine them now you take care
of them
and i know that for a fact i have a
friend who's who's worth 14 billion
dollars
billion with a b he was just partying at
my house all night long wouldn't leave
four in the morning go home
and he flew in from canada to go to my
new year's party because
he loves my family connection and he
doesn't have one
he is financially wealthy he's
relationship broke
does that make sense abundance is a 360
experience
it's about relationships it's about
health it's about your spiritual
groundness that doesn't mean you have a
religious origin
it's about can you release can you
forgive can you let go
can you be still do you meditate do you
have time with yourself
that has a lot to do with the quality of
your life we spend so
much time and energy trying to prevent
ourselves from falling
we spend so much energy trying to
prevent a failure
we spend so much energy making sure
we're safe
and if we spent 70 percent of that
energy
exploring how we can soar exploring how
we can play bigger
exploring how we can make memories that
we absolutely will be
excited to tell when we're 85 years old
sitting in our favorite rocking chair
if we spent 40 50
of that same energy how would our lives
look differently
i'm not saying be reckless i'm not
saying do it without a plan
what i am saying is so many times i get
the question
how do i prevent failure and i'd love
for you
to spend that same energy going how
could i
ensure that i soar how can i ensure
that i live the life that i want to tell
people about
that i write the story that's going to
be really really good to read
so number one is shift your energy on
what you want to create
versus what you want to prevent because
energy grows where energy goes
if you've looked at several episodes
you've probably heard me say that before
not because i've run out of content but
because i want to keep saying it because
repetition is not the mother and father
of learning
repetition is the mother father sister
brother aunt and uncle and second cousin
of learning
so i'm going to keep telling you this
that energy grows
where energy goes so while we want to
mitigate and reduce our risk of falling
reduce our risk of failure we want to
spend our dominant
energy on creating possibility and what
we want to run toward
now i say that i say that from lessons
learned not just as a teacher but
because i
for many years in the early part of my
career unbeknownst to me
unconsciously i wasn't running toward
possibility
i was trying to outrun 11 and 42 cents
in the bank like i had in 1994
and so i know that once i was able to
get far enough away from that experience
i started losing motivation i stopped
running as fast i didn't know it
i didn't know why but it's because i
knew i wasn't threatened
by ever seeing 11.42 cents again
and then i'd ru all my motivation was
gone i was nervous for about a year
i was still in motion still you know
generating a lot of business a lot of
buzz but internally i wasn't
driven the same way until i
shifted my energy and said what am i
running toward
the first answer was i don't know
because i've been
trying to outrun something so long that
i wasn't looking
forward really looking for like horizon
for
like up for it i may have been looking
at the next goal for
the next target for but i wasn't looking
at horizon something so big
it would take me 10 years to get there
it would take me 15
years to get there and so number one
let's create a big bodacious
like yummy in five years i want to be
here in 10 years i want to have this
let's create something to run toward
that makes your knees knock a bit
and it stretches you it doesn't stress
you it stretches you
i run into so many people all around the
world who
are living this duality one
i want more but two i don't want to
disrupt what i have
and the challenge is in order for you to
have a breakthrough to the next level
your
yours your standard your average and
your ordinary
has to be disrupted people say oh lisa
how do i do this
and i go do this this this and this i
give you the steps
and the next thing they say is hmm
that's so hard
i'm sorry did you think your breath
taking life
would come on a merry-go-round did you
think you're going to do the swings and
get there
you're going to sweat so get up
ready to sweat get up ready to forgive
the perceivingly unforgivable
get up ready to take the higher road
even when
the smallness in you wants to get
engaged avoid the fight because the
fight keeps you in the little you
when you're committed to being the
bigger version of yourself
yeah you're gonna have to say some
things you never said
and do some things you've never done so
you can meet the man the woman
you've always known yourself to be this
whole piece in my book abundance now i
wrote it a while ago and it's amazing in
terms of just talking about and breaking
down
what's the difference between a macro
win
and a micro win and a micro win is that
smaller goal that's you could see it's
attainable
you get that instant result and most
people are chasing the macro win
all the time and they're not looking at
all the micro wins that they can feel
really good about to get them to that
macro result because if you create
five seven eight ten micro wins guess
what
now you're in a rhythm now you're
building some consistency now you like
the way it feels
and then before you know it you look up
and go whoa there's that
macro win that huge goal
that i thought was a hundred miles away
it wasn't a hundred miles away
it was seven eight eleven micro wins
away
success is personally defined by
everyone
and as you're creating success create
holistic success
my bit my biggest successes are the
things that people don't even see
it's the fact that my 14 year old son
calls me his best friend
to his friends that's bigger that's
bigger than any book deal that you can
give me that's bigger than sitting
across from larry king or beside oprah
that my 14 year old son
calls me his best friend creating
holistic success is really
important let me tell you in order to
have something different you are going
to have to do something different
in order to have something more you have
to do something you haven't done yet
i had to say the things i didn't want to
say do the things i didn't feel like
doing to have the life i know i want it
period period
and all i did was give instructions for
here do this bite size do this bite size
do this bite size
bite size digestible palatable pieces of
what you can do
does that sound good you guys and when
you look up and you don't have to have a
magnificent change
over 12 months have a small change over
30 days and then a small change over 30
days
your breakthrough comes will come in
needlepoint moves
and you'll look up look up in five years
and not recognize your life
when you look at prioritizing it really
lives in and i'm a say this word
and you're probably not going to want to
hear it but when i tell you it's a game
changer
when you master and just for now begin
to operate inside of time management
i used to resist time management because
i'm i'm a
free spirit slash people would call me a
rebel back in the day
meaning i didn't want to be controlled i
wanted i'm a butterfly i wanted to i
wanted to soar i wanted to
be free well the reality is that when
you manage your time more effectively
you actually create more freedom that
was
a huge aha for me somebody's going to be
oll right now like breakthrough
out loud because when you time manage
meaning
i'm going to use better blocks of my
time let me give you some examples for
that
i'm going to use better blocks of my
time meaning i'm only going to go in my
email
three times a day i go on my email about
9
30 between 9 20 and 9 40 i go on my
email
i stay in my email for 30 minutes i'll
go back in my email
about three o'clock in the afternoon i
stay in my email again
for about 30 minutes i go back on my
email one more time
at 6 00 pm i stay in for about 30
minutes that's it i don't go in 19 times
i don't go on 20 times because three
times a day gives me adequate time to
see what's in there see what's new
and act appropriately otherwise it's
throwing me off
i i time block my day about 90 minutes
each time blocked to do a task even if a
task only takes me 30 minutes
i time block 90 minutes because i get
distracted but when you time block your
your day and then you schedule each day
not every day looks the same i have a
time block for everything i need to do
for seven days out the week can you
believe that in that time i got
more things done you have to become
comfortable
with your no my grandmother says baby
she starts every sentence with baby baby
if you want your yes to have more value
you need to learn how to exercise your
no see your yes might not have
its value anymore why because you give
it away too much
you give it to too many people you give
it away too often
you're always over committing and then
you feel drained
and frustrated and you don't have
gratitude in your heart because you're
over committed
well that all started with a yes
that should have been a no or should
have been a
i'd love to but not now and so
number two number one is more effective
time management that has your agenda in
it
that has your prior priorities in it
right now your agenda is covered with
everyone else's
task i heard once if you don't have
your agenda then you're going to work
for somebody else's agenda
and so number one is your time manager
with your agenda and number two
is operating utilizing and being
comfortable in a no
and not an attitude no nothing like a
thank you
like now not that just a no not now
you know i i i would love to but my
plate is full
i'm free in 90 days just don't make
no no energy just not now don't be
surprised when everyone comes to you
you're great you're amazing you're
brilliant
look at you you're on this channel so
you know you're smart you want a better
life you want
an abundant life of course you're here
of course everyone wants you
and your priorities matter so when you
talk about
making your dash dance point one
you got to be willing to do it afraid
see you might be waiting for the fear to
stop lisa i heard this so many times
lisa
i'm afraid what do i do do it anyway
lisa i'm afraid i don't quite know if i
should move
move anyway i don't know if i should
leap
leap afraid
and then gather your courage on the way
down
and if you don't get it before you hit
you was gonna hit anyway
i'd rather die leaping than on the edge
figuring out how to get the courage to
leap yes yes
yes yes so many times we're
waiting we're waiting i'm waiting i'm
waiting to get something right i see
your hands going up you guys know
if it's your truth you can raise your
hand just like we did on day zero
you're just kind of waiting you're
waiting to get everything in order
you're waiting you're waiting so that
everything is is in you it's together
you're waiting to
not be afraid you're waiting to have the
courage you're waiting to have all the
money you're waiting
to lose weight
see see if i waited to release my
unwanted pounds before i got in front of
you
lisa nichols would be the secret
yes yes i thought how about i
just leap with my imperfection and then
find my form of perfecting my
imperfection while i'm soaring
how about i do that how about i not how
about you not wait to get it right
you look at you figure out how does it
look doing it wrong
how does that look because you're 80 of
right as somebody else's 159
of what they needed yes yes and when you
want to do it right and you want to wait
til you're not afraid and you want to
wait till you have it all together
oh you made it about you again
see nelson mandela did it he just did it
not knowing if it were right
mahatma gandhi just did it not knowing
if it were right
mother teresa just did it not looking
for affirmation or confirmation
is this right martin luther king did it
not even knowing if it would happen
before his life
ended i mean what are you waiting on
are you willing to do it afraid are you
willing to do it
knowing that you got so much work to do
to get it better to get it
more perfect but are you willing to do
it inside your imperfection do you
realize that in your imperfection you're
perfect for the job
visualization is a gift to your heart
and your soul it's a gift because if the
the idea
is the seed visualization
is the is the um it's the fertilizer
it's the fertilizer because when your
thoughts
are connected with an emotion see you
would visualize yourself winning
and you would feel all the emotion that
came with that and all you're doing now
is you're not chasing a foreign emotion
you know the feeling
and now you're just doing what's
necessary to get back to that feeling in
real time
exactly and so what what a good friend
of mine vishen um
of the ceo of mine valley who you know
um i would i did a visualization with
him we were in bali
and um he said to me afterwards i never
get emotional
he does it he doesn't get emotional he's
like right right yeah
well he was like i cried i got emotional
he goes i figured it out it's
visualization
a good visualization brings an emotion
he was like that's how you do it and so
um i i love doing visualizations because
and it's really important in the
visualization you can't see it over
there
you have to see it right here you got to
feel it right here like i
am it's all i am i am i am
in my dream home i am in my dream
relationship and then unpack what that
looks like
but most importantly unpack what it
feels like and when you
have that that emotion in this moment
all of a sudden you stir up something
that i don't think will ever go back to
sleep it'll go okay let's go get that
and what it really does is it sets up a
state of cognitive dissonance
and cognitive dissonance is when you see
something in your mind
and you see yourself in a way that your
behaviors are not currently
leading to and so your mind becomes
disrupted and it goes
okay can we get there right because i'm
out there right now not there right now
and that's not comfortable your mind
wants to literally be congruent
what it thinks is what you're doing what
it thinks is what you're doing and so
when you set
up a constant and abundant thinkers like
you and i we do it unconsciously
we are constantly keeping ourselves in a
state
of cognitive dissonance meaning okay
what else and i'm
seeing lisa over there and i'm going
okay let me go
wow while being grateful for my now
yeah it's not in that i'm gonna be whole
and complete when i get over there
i'm holding complete now i just know i'm
supposed to be over there so let me do
what's necessary to get over there and
let me
let me evict any behaviors or
characteristics that are stopping me and
let me adopt any new ones that i need
when you ask the question or when you
look at the question how do i
create a life of prosperity when i
haven't known it
when my family hasn't known it when it's
not what we're
uh it's not what i was born into you
know there are many people was born who
were born into prosperity
i wasn't one and you may or may not be
one
but how you transform a life or create a
life of prosperity is number one you
identify what does prosperity look like
to you
define prosperity by your own terms
and don't make it a global universal
answer
you want to just define prosperity in
each area of your life
what does health prosperity look like
for you for me health prosperity wasn't
necessarily weighing
120 pounds i don't know i don't know
when i weighed i think i was 10 years
old when i
weighed 110 pounds i don't ever recall
weighing 110 pounds as an adult
so i don't pursue a particular weight on
the skit on the scale
for me health prosperity is i want my
body to be able to keep up with my life
purpose
i want my body to be able to live out
the things that i want to do
such as skiing and surfing and
bungee jumping in whatever other crazy
things i want to do
so that's health prosperity to me what
does relationship prosperity look like
to you
what does family relationship prosperity
look like what does friendship
relationship prosperity look like what
does romantic
relationship run i know that sounds like
it's really detailed but you cannot hit
a moving target you won't ever hit a
moving target so the more detail you get
the more the target slows down and you
hit it
so first define what does prosperity
look like for you
in each area of your life that matters
if that area of your life isn't
important
don't define prosperity there because
you don't even have a desire
to have prosperity in that area because
that's not important to you
so every area in your life that's
important first tell us what the target
is what's the target
and that's prosperity now you have to
know that you're going to outgrow that
prosperity
in two years four years five years and
then you'll set another target in the
air of prosperity
the things that i wanted 10 years ago
are way too small for me now
the things i wanted five years ago i've
totally outgrown so you're constantly
resetting this target
the second thing you want to do is you
want to find a buy when date
we never put a buy one day we rarely
rarely say we rarely put a buy when date
on the calendar
and because we don't put it by wind it
on the calendar we think someday in one
day
well if you can't circle some day and
one day on the calendar
then you can pretty much bet it doesn't
exist how many go
how many times are you looking for a
goal and you said
one day and that one day is still on its
way
listen put a date on the calendar i know
the things that i'm doing
18 months from now i know what i want to
have done in
q2 of next year because
i said by the end by june
30th on this date i don't have this done
so what it does is it doesn't
require me to do anything now because
i'm busy with something else
but i do know that i want that to happen
a by one day jumps you
into action the third thing how do you
create prosperity
after you've set the goal clearly after
you put a deal on the calendar
grab someone that's going to hold you
accountable to the thing that you say
you want
now there are many other things to do in
the middle but these are some of the
anchors that will allow you to really
get there
one you want to make sure you understand
what it
is number two you want to make sure you
understand
by when do you want that thing to occur
in your life and oh by the way be kind
to yourself
most of the time the majority of time we
set a goal
the place that we fail ourselves every
time
is that not the goal the goal doesn't
fail us but the
unrealistic by when date i i've done it
a thousand times i want to lose 30
pounds
i give myself 30 days well i probably
could but man i got other life i haven't
given
any any thought to all the other things
happening in my life so be kind to
yourself
with your by wednesdays but don't be
lackadaisical and don't be ambiguous
with some day or one day
give yourself a date then the third
thing is get someone that's not afraid
of you
get someone that's playing as big or
bigger than you
to hold you accountable to not only
getting there not only those goals
but how are you going to get there and
what are the incremental milestones that
you're going to show
on your way there so i'm not just
focused on the
end date i want to know what are the
incremental milestones what are the
what lets me know i'm on the right track
it's like whenever someone's giving me
directions i don't care about gps
i go listen what should i see should i
see a starbucks
should i say mcdonald's should i see a
jumbo juice what should i see on my way
there
because i want to know that i'm on the
right path and you want to do that you
want to
create milestones to let you know you're
on the right path
accountability communities by wind dates
and clarity those are the beginning
steps
of changing and transforming your life
into a place of prosperity but every if
that's step number one
that that's one two three and four then
please know that zero
is mining your mindset
because first you have to actually
believe that you can have it
that will take some work at times what
you believed you can have five years ago
been there done that what you believe
what you should be believing you can
have ten years from now
you might require a little work a little
stretching so step zero
is mindset always mindset then one two
three four and five are the action steps
that i told you
remember this show is not a monologue no
no no no no
this show is a dialogue this is a
conversation between you
and i i know that sounds like it's
really detailed but you cannot hit
a moving target you won't ever hit a
moving talk so the more detail you get
the more the target slows down and you
hit it
when we talk about living our quest
um i think that living my quest
really if i look at on a daily basis
it's finding my own voice
it's finding your voice it's finding the
song
that only you can sing
off-key or not it's finding your rhythm
it's discovering what it feels like to
walk
in your shoes today it won't look like
it looked 10 years ago
living your quest is
what can i do with my life so that my
life becomes infectious to someone else
living my quest looks like how do i
make my fingerprint matter so big that
it lives beyond my transition day
living your quest is how can i forgive
the perceivingly unforgivable so i can
love the absolute lovable
living your quest is how do i
give myself a thousand second chances
and every time i get to 9.99 press reset
yeah yeah
living my quest is is not some ambiguous
untouchable experience living my quest
means going back and healing the little
girl in me
so that the woman can be free it's going
back and embracing
the little boy in you so that the man
can show up and give himself permission
to cry when necessary
living your quest is not something that
you can't touch
it's not something that requires a stage
or lights or cameras
living your quest is being completely
content with who you
are in the dark of the night so who you
are in the middle of the day is all
right
living your quest is as simple as it is
complex living your quest is about
giving yourself
permission say permission on a daily
basis
to become the next best version of
yourself
living your quest is not holding
yourself hostage to old decisions
not holding yourself hostage to shame
blame guilt regret
and anger living your quest is about
recognizing that every day i can be
reborn
to my possibility see
living your quest is as internal and
personal as it is public
living your quest is about recognizing
that you have brilliance in you
and not being willing to dim your light
one more day
living your quest means not being afraid
of the genius in you even though you
have doubt
living your quest is recognizing that
you get to sing your song
off tune that you can get to live in
perfection while you
master imperfection you know i love the
phrase
willpower but willpower isn't something
you conjure up
willpower isn't something you drink
willpower isn't something you download
from google
what you're talking about is how do i
make the choices
that are in alignment with my highest
purpose and my highest vision
for myself that's what you really want
to ask
see your life is a physical
manifestation
of the choices that you made up into
this moment i'm going to say that again
because that gets a little deep
and that can go over some people's head
that can hit you sometimes right between
the eyes
and you got to hear the second time so
here it goes your life
right now as it exists today your
finances
your weight your relationships your
career
your self-esteem your self-image your
spiritual awareness
all of that is a result of the choices
that you've made
up into this moment big and small
and just so you know your life the way
it appears today
is not a result of a few big choices
even though that's the thing that we
look back on we go ah
i shouldn't have moved out of the state
i shouldn't have gotten into that
relationship
i shouldn't have we look at the big
things well i'm here to disrupt that
mindset a bit
your life experience right now is not so
much a result of your big choices why
those
impact you it's really a result of a
bunch of small
little choices made consistently over a
long
period of time because those are the
habits and the behaviors that you've
gotten into
so we can talk about willpower and how
do i build willpower as if it's
something that you can
flex in the gym or something you can do
crunches or abs or triceps and build
but it's not the question you should ask
the answer you should be seeking is what
does it take
to make my choices become an alignment
with the life that i say i want to live
now when you say choices it makes it
really sobering
because even when you choose to sit down
on yourself
it was a choice so i ask you in this
moment
what will it take you to decide to make
the choice today
don't even think about tomorrow don't
think about next week but to make the
choice today
that's in alignment with your health
goals make a choice today that's in
alignment with your financial goals
it's the small things it's the extra
visit to starbucks
it's the extra biscuit it's the giving
up early it's 10 more crunches
it's doing squats every time you go to
the bathroom at least that's what i do i
do ten
i do ten every time i go to the restroom
i'm already there i'm just gonna keep on
going
just because i wanna stay in alignment
with my goal and my goal is to have
a body that at least creates a double
take
or or triple date maybe i don't know
i wanted to create a body that is in
alignment with my goal i want to be able
to go paintballing with my nephews
and my son the way i just did recently i
want to be able to go
jet skiing so when i look at my life and
my lifestyle that i want to maintain
it requires me to hike a little longer
it requires me to
eat more vegetables and protein it
requires me my my choice of how i want
to live
requires my alignment and what i put in
my body or how i stay active in my body
so when i date i don't i don't do dinner
dates i'm not interested in doing dinner
dates you want to date me
let's go on a hike let's go skating ice
skating roller skating it's going to
walk
i want active dates in my dating
experience because that's an alignment
with my life's purpose so what are you
choosing
let's not even look at willpower let's
look at choices
because choice is something you can
control in every single moment
and the choice you made yesterday if it
was in alignment with your greatest goal
and your highest purpose
okay yesterday yesterday make a new
choice today you're not
ever condemned or sentenced to making
the same choice over and over and over
again
every day every moment you have a new
opportunity
to make a new choice you know as an
entrepreneur
you know there's so many years where i
worked
the day away the night away
but way beyond working the day and the
night away
i worked memories away i worked
parts of my life away i worked
sacred moments away i want to warn you
i want to warn you about working so hard
to create an amazing future
that you miss a million now
so busy creating that future where your
children
or your family or your parents or your
significant other
will have everything they want
in the moment you're robbing them from
the one thing they need
you your time i know
that our intentions are good and i say
ours cause i'm right there with you
um i would grind every day in my walk-in
closet i transform my walk-in closet
into my office
i would walk my son to school come back
put my head down my elbows up
and i would come up for air just enough
to walk to school pick him up
bring him back fix them a fast lunch i
go back down
and then i come back up at dinner time
and then i go
back down and i did it for year after
year after
year after year and i looked up and i
forgot the things i like
i forgot the excursions that i want to
go on i forgot my favorite food because
my favorite food was whatever was
fastest
and quickest and can get me back to work
i thought that the sacrifice was okay
that it's okay to sacrifice at this
level and wow
there is a necessary sacrifice there is
a necessary level of inconvenience
there also is a required and oh by all
means a desired amount of memories
that you want to make sure you make now
i wrote my book abundance now and i
remember having
conversations with the publishers and
others about
the now you know because whether it was
abundant life or abundance and
prosperity or abundance beyond the
secret
another title it was important for me
to write abundance now because
there's nothing more valuable than
you're
now so yes i'm going to encourage you to
work hard
i'm going to encourage you to grind but
i'm going to remind you
that when you're sitting in your rocking
chair and there's nothing else for you
to do
you have played full out you've made all
the money you're going to make
you've bought all the properties you're
going to buy you've done all the
business you can do and you've attended
all the meetings there are to attend
and all that's left to do now is to sit
inside your memories
you're going to want to have a lot of
really great memories we
so often we wear labels there's a label
that's to me there's several labels i'm
an african-american
woman i'm a single mom you know i'm a
ceo i'm a daughter there's so many
labels to me
but i don't live under the label
i allow the label to exist but it
doesn't define me
and so i invite you if you are a woman
you know there's so many men watching my
channel i love you
i want you to always come you're always
welcome
this is your home but to my sisters
i invite you don't feel like life is
harder for you because you're a woman
don't feel like you have to work harder
because you're a woman
work hard just work hard i never looked
at
am i working harder as a woman am i
working harder as a black person now are
there
inequities absolutely i am not blind to
that
but like i said in a previous episode
energy grows
where energy goes am i going to give the
inequities energy or am i going to give
the possibility energy
and i'm not saying that everything's
hunky-dory and all things are right no
there are some wrongs that really need
to be corrected
but here is what i won't do i won't wear
a label
and walk in a room living under that
label
wondering how you're going to treat me
because of that label people used to ask
lisa how did you get on the main stage
with people like tony robbins and
and jack canfield and people like you
know they rattle off all these
uh older white men are very successful
white speakers in the industry and they
say how did you get on stage with them
as a black woman
or how did you get on stage with him as
a woman and i go
i didn't get on stage with him as a
woman i got on stage with him as a
badass speaker
i got on stage with him as someone who
can bring value to the audience
i got on stage with them because i'm a
change agent so
can you live through the results that
you produce in the world can you allow
that to define you
like this is the bag that you were given
a woman a man
black white indian asian the religion
you were born into the economic status
you grew up under
all of those things are boxes that
someone else said let's drop you in it
and then you have to choose if you're
going to stay in it
i am too big to be defined by a box
any box any label of any size
why don't you join that so don't be
successful as a woman
be successful don't be successful as a
man
be successful don't be loving and giving
as a black person or white person or
asian person be
loving and giving just be
and then be con become contagious for
someone else
to want to be that way because they
crossed your path
you are only going to go as far as you
think you're worthy
i can push you can push you you can have
the greatest product
but if you don't feel worthy you will
work hard to sabotage that relationship
you don't know everybody right you don't
know you're doing you think these are
the things i need
and you're driving that guy away you're
driving that woman away
because your self-worth says they
weren't going to stay forever anyway
or self-worth around money you have a
cap
that you feel like you're worthy of a
million dollars you will always get
to 999 thousand and you will stop
because your self-worth says
what's a good exercise or process that
we can follow on a daily basis maybe
something simple
to enhance our enrichment absolutely
worthiness absolutely
i did this for six months every single
day right after i brush my teeth
and and it's the i see you exercise
and you get in the mirror now it it's
not necessarily simple
because because you're dealing with
yourself of course and as complicated as
you are
we'll be the mechanics of it are simple
mechanics are very simple yes
i appreciate that distinction um you get
in the mirror and you complete three
different sentences you want to write
this down
the first sentence you look at yourself
and you say your name so you say louis
and you complete this is i'm proud that
you and find seven different things
every day to celebrate yourself for
seven different
each day you can do the same thing you
did the day before but each day do seven
different things to be proud of
the second sentence is gonna knock you
down a little bit it's gonna
come from your gut um louis
i forgive you for and cut the shackles
to blame
shame guilt regret and anger in that
sentence you cut those five shackles
not the first day maybe not the third
day but by the 21st day
by the 13th day you'll feel some relief
so louis i forgive you for
and go back five years 15 years 20 years
do that
forgive you for that thing don't nobody
know about but you go ahead and cut
those shackles
because if you can still think about it
it's still in your energy space
and then the third sentence is louis i
commit to you that
before you make a commitment to anybody
else throughout your day
you make seven commitments to you so the
first sentence is i'm proud that you
you're celebrating yourself first
we are under celebrated as a as a
society we
look for acknowledgement they enter they
interviewed a hundred
executives that all made over a quarter
of a million dollars and said would you
like a five percent raise next year or
would you rather be told thank you more
often
100 100 said keep your money
i'd rather hear thank you so we're under
celebrated but first celebrate you
be the example when i was on oprah when
she said what do you do i said i
recognize that i'm the example
of how the rest of the world is supposed
to treat me and it's my job to give the
world the best example of how i like to
be treated
so celebrate yourself forgive yourself
cut the shackles
and then commit to yourself before you
commit to anyone else that right there
powerful that right there will begin to
fill your cup up
to get to your salsa i love that our
desire to say
yes to everyone really is less about
them
and more about our need to be approved
our need to be perceived loving
kind and generous now i know that might
be hard to hear
but when you don't have the ability to
say no
it really isn't about the people that
you're saying no to
it's about you not wanting to draw a
healthy boundary not wanting to
turn someone away not wanting to risk
the fact that you might not make someone
happy with you
in the moment go underneath that and say
why
am i having that challenge the answer to
that is the core
of why you don't want to say no because
i want to be liked and loved all the
time
because i don't want to experience
rejection because i want people to see
me as a giving loving person
because because because because now
none of those are wrong but can you
already
know that about yourself and if you know
you're loving
if you know you're kind if you know
you're giving
if you know that you're generous then
you can say healthy yeses
when you need to say yes and you can say
a healthy no
well you need to say no my grandmother
says
if you want your yes to have the most
value
possible then sweetie you need to learn
how to exercise your no
because if you keep telling everyone yes
you actually diminish
the value of your yes because i'm not
grateful that you said yes as a matter
of fact
i expected you to say yes why
because you always say yes you know the
whole fake it till you make it
well i don't want to fake it forever i
have no interest in faking it forever
but i do want to play like i'm
courageous enough
until my courage appears i want to
pretend
like i'm not afraid
until i'm not afraid
i want a fake like i
know how to do this business i know how
to
surrender to this love and
while pursuing the ability to know how
to do this business
pursue the understanding of knowing how
to surrender to love i don't think
there's a place in your life
that when you're playing bigger than
you've played before that you won't feel
nervous you won't feel a little afraid
and at times you won't have a sense of
the imposter syndra
what if what if you're not an imposter
in the career you're in you're not an
impostor in the relationship you're not
imposter
in the entrepreneurial business what if
what if you're just learning
what if you visualize the seven foot
tall you and the five eight six
one six two five two version of you
is still typical to grow to that
individual
you are not a victim to anything
there is not something that's been
bestowed upon your family
that generationally has to occur over
and over and over again
there are habits there are awareness
and there are actions and when you
change your habits
expand your awareness and elevate your
action
you can change a curse into a blessing
i get asked the question a lot how do i
jump start again
when i've been complacent you know i i
found that i had to ask myself this
question as well for so many years
i was working hard to feed jaylani i was
working hard to give him an equal chance
i had this goal that by the time he was
18 i would
have transformed our lives and i ran
hard for it and i worked hard for it and
by the time it was 18 our lives were
completely transformed and barely
recognizable
and i found that i had slowed down a bit
still
running but running at about 70 percent
and the challenge that you have to watch
out for
is that your 70 could be someone else's
115
because you are such a game changer so
you can impress a lot of people
never playing full out and you can look
up in a year's past
three years has passed five years have
passed and you haven't played full out
for a while because you've already
achieved a lot by
some people's standards but there's
still so much more that you can
do i want to coach you in this way dream
a dream
or set a goal that's big enough to make
you get nervous
oftentimes if you're not setting a goal
that's beyond three years out in front
of you there's not enough to run for
so i want you to look at your goals can
you achieve them in a year
two years i want you to set a goal for
three years set a goal for five years
and set a goal for 10 years
yes i said 10 years when i did this
phenomenal program called lifebook
they had me set 10-year goals and i was
so uncomfortable i sat there
silent for a moment i hadn't thought 10
years out about my life
but if you go out far enough 10 5
3. then all of a sudden you're playing
for something so much bigger
and then set a goal that makes your
knees knock and your teeth chatter a bit
if you know how to get to your goal
you're not dreaming big enough
now the goal also has to be realistic so
has to be realistic
something you can do if you're currently
making 80 000 then
your goal in three years isn't to make
500 000
unless you have a path that's viable to
get you there that's
real the thing that's really important
to remember about a goal
is that if you set lofty goals that you
will never hit because they're not
realistic in the first place you have to
set realistic goals that
doesn't mean you're not capable doesn't
mean that you don't believe in yourself
but realistic goals
if you set a bunch of unrealistic goals
and you don't hit them every time you
don't hit a goal you
you lose just a little bit of hope in
yourself a little bit of faith in
yourself
and then what happens is you look up
five years ten years from now
and you're not dreaming anymore you're
not setting goals anymore you're afraid
to tell anyone
so set a goal that makes your knees
knock and your teeth chatter a bit
set a goal that's three years out in
front of you set one that's five years
and set one as ten years as a matter of
fact set several and all those timelines
and then hook your caboose to the train
of other people who are running as fast
as you are
surround yourself in a community that
inspires you to want to stand
on your tippy toes they inspire you
because they're doing so much
now they believe in values they believe
in faith they believe in family but they
also believe in running hard
playing hard and living big because if
you're the biggest fish in your
community
then that's okay you just need to get a
second community to play inside of as
well
and so if you find yourself going hold
on i've become complacent
walk out 15 years and go do i want to
look back in 15 years
and this was the best that i did the
answer probably
is no so the first thing i said
was i'm done with this level of misery
so i didn't run toward anything first
the first thing i did was try to get as
far
away from chaos and scarcity
and lack and procrastination and
procrastinating people
and and making excuses making being a
single mom an excuse or being black an
excuse or being born in l.a an excuse
not to say those things don't impede or
have an
impact on our ability to move forward
but i didn't want to make any one of
them my crutch
yes as to why i stayed in my hellhole
i don't know about anyone else but my
place i i didn't know where i was going
but i knew where i was leaving again you
say your name first
lisa i commit to you that
and you make seven different commitments
to yourself
that before you go out of your door and
you commit to other people
because you know we're more apt to honor
our commitment to other people than we
are to honor our commitment to ourselves
we break our commitments to ourselves
all the time and yet when i give you my
word
oh man you can bet your last dime on
that word and you will end up with 20
cents
but what happens when you begin to
commit to yourself you'll see that
making commitments to you
not only feel as good as making
commitments to other people
but they feel better because when you
show up for you
you serve everybody else from your
overflow
one of the big things that i've learned
is that the more i owned
my own authority the more i can honor
other people's
awareness i know where they are the more
i stood in my own grace and compassion
the more i can honor the grace and
compassion of others the more
i owned my no the more grateful i
was for other people's yeses so it's
just one of these things where the more
you work on you
the more you turn the mirror to you
versus pointing at everyone else the
more you turn the mirror to you and work
on you
man the dynamics between you and
everyone else
just gets richer i became a more
compassionate
more giving more loving friend
when i became more compassionate giving
and loving to lisa
and so when i say to you i didn't choose
the
i didn't choose the possibility first i
just stopped choosing the chaos
see there's there's a couple of several
choices you have to make
because you know your answers are going
to come with the ceiling opening and
lights beaming in and the choir
showing up and like no that doesn't
happen like that
you know if the first thing is i was
sick of smelling my own crap
i was sick of hearing my own story i was
sick
of wondering about my own potential
so i realized that everything i had done
had gotten me where i was and everything
i didn't know
was gonna get me somewhere else you're
gonna play big say big
you're gonna play huge say huge you're
gonna play
ginormous say ginormous
but first take baby steps you're gonna
eat the elephant
but take one small bite first chew it
good
right we want so much so fast
my grandmother says baby she starts
every sentence with baby
i'm sure it's because she cannot
remember all of our names
she said baby the best things you'll
ever have from grandma
will never come from the microwave they
always come from the oven
and i was like i think some somehow
she's trying to give me a lesson here
and and i realized that the best things
that you're going to create are going to
take time
build it on cement not sinking sand
you're going to get tons and tons and
tons of tools here and you're going to
want to fast forward
when you fast forward you're building on
plexiglass you've been on styrofoam
you've been on wood you want to build it
on semen your dream is important enough
to outlive you
yes yes and so i realized that
that you can't google download
resiliency
you can't google download tenacity you
can't google download forgiveness there
are some of the best qualities and
characteristics
that's going to take you a long way that
you need to invest time in
and energy in an intention in you don't
just get
patience i want patience i'm waiting for
somebody's going to piss you off
tomorrow
and now you get to test if you have
patience i realized
i realized that as i wanted to develop
me i had to be willing to climb and i
wanted to get to the top and there's no
elevator to the top i gotta do my squats
i gotta work on my quads and my
hamstrings and my calves
because i gotta climb to the top we got
a climb
abundant thinkers keep themselves in a
constant state of
cognitive dissonance write that down
abundant thinkers keep themselves in a
constant state
a constant state of cognitive
dissonance you're creative spell it any
way you want
now what is cognitive dissonance
cognitive dissonance
is when you have literally thought about
a version of yourself that you're not
currently living right now
meaning the thought that you have of
yourself your behaviors are not
congruent with
so your mind becomes disrupted your mind
says wait a minute
you're seeing me here but my behaviors
aren't here and when you keep yourself
in a constant state your mind begins to
influence your behaviors to be congruent
with your thought
next level cognitive
dissonance abundant thinkers that's why
he went out to the ocean
that's why he's up on stage because
constantly seeing himself further than
what his behaviors want to really do
and then when he does it now i got that
down constantly
now is being grateful for your now yes
yes
being grateful for your now but clearly
seeing where you're going and not
resting until you get there if you have
a lot of ideas
a lot of things that you want to do a
lot of write them out
and i make columns for each one so i
don't put them all together because
they're each
on almost like on separate islands which
is why you feel so fragmented
or overwhelmed or whatever that might be
so i write out make columns and then i
just put the id at the top of the column
and i just write out everything that i
have in my head about an idea until i
feel like
okay i got that out once i have them out
then i attach a timeline to when i'm
gonna start it
and ideally complete it now let's be
clear
the timeline of when you're going to
start it and complete it are going to
move
so don't get stressed out about the
timeline you made it up i'm going to say
that again
when you create a timeline you made it
up
which means you get to modify what you
made up at any given time
but i give myself a start and a
completion date now here's the key thing
there are things that i give a start
date to that i'm not even going to
start for two years
for 18 months matter of fact i'll do
like let's say i'm in the second quarter
of this year
i'll put in one of those columns my
start date is the second quarter
of next year so i know i'm going to get
to it
i know i'm going to get to it it's
called what am i doing now
and what am i not doing now but i'm
doing it i'm just not doing it now oh
man can i tell you don't sleep on that
little nugget right there i learned that
from my coach susie carter
that there's you're doing now and then
there's your doing
but not now so it's on the calendar
everything that you're doing should be
on the calendar there's the doing now
it has a place on the calendar that
you're actively in and then there's a
doing
not now because it's on the calendar so
i have some great projects i'm excited
about
i don't start them for like another 10
months
and then i put all my other projects on
the from these columns
inside of these current 10 months and so
now
you are doing it because you have a
start date but you're not overwhelmed
with it because it's not all vying for
your spacing your attention
in the now how can you stay humble
you know as you amass more success
how can you stay humble while owning
your brilliance
i believe that there's two very separate
intentions running here
number one own your brilliance don't
question it
you don't have to grandize it you don't
have to you don't have to highlight it
you don't have to
have your brilliance and your talent
spew over onto other people and
and and minimize their greatness when
you live
in your light you don't have to promote
it
or diminish it you simply live in it
i notice a lot of times when people are
successful
they have a tendency to want to remind
you that
they are successful they remind you in
the way they speak to you they remind
you and the fact that they're always
coaching you they remind you and
whatever however the status thing that
they do
to me that's not owning your brilliance
or your success that's trying to prove
it
that's trying to remind you of it and a
lot of times people want to remind you
or prove to you something
when they're still wondering if it's
true
so number one own your light
unapologetically
like don't try to dim your light nor
should you try to turn it up
just let it be rise the tide from who
you're being
rise the tide from your service when i
say nor should you try to turn it up
that's not saying don't tap into the
greatest version of you
that means don't artificially try to
turn it up
so everyone in the room knows that
you're great you don't have to do that
you don't have to say it
you don't have to announce it you don't
have to try to remind me of it just be
it
but by the same token don't try to hide
it
practice active self-care that means
you're not talking about the spa that
you want to go to you're not talking
about the nap that you need to take
you're not talking about the weekend you
want to get away to
you're actually doing it so i want you
to take a moment
to reflect and identify what rejuvenates
you
now they're not it's not always
something huge something big
something ginormous but it's something
that allows you to write this
down recalibrate your energy
what keeps your energy in calm so many
times we're working out of anxiety
need or stress stress is the number one
killer it's the number one
robber of life and joy what do we do
actively what do you do actively that
will rejuvenate you
what's available to you i want you to
write down
a strategy about how and when
you'll make time for self-care during
this busy time
i start every day with 25 things that
i'm grateful for
and all 25 things have to cost 25
or less so i can be grateful for my car
grateful for my home
while i can be grateful during this
exercise i'm grateful for the time that
i spent cooking in
in the kitchen with my son this weekend
i'm grateful for the walks that my
grandmother takes me on i used to say i
take her on walks
then i realized she was educating me
that she takes me on walks
i'm grateful for the fact that i still
dance with my daddy
i'm grateful for the moments my nephew
climbs in my bed so we can watch
our latest greatest movie together i'm
grateful for
mustard man and garlic girl in the
kitchen cooking that's my son and i
every single thing that i find gratitude
for is something that helps to make me
who i am and i gotta tell you
something happens when you live park
and stay cemented in gratitude i
i call that if your dream is the seed
then gratitude is the fertilizer
and so gratitude constant gratitude
recognizing that you are a servant
leader with a servant's
heart and when you say the word servant
servant and ego just don't go together
servant is to serve but not a servant
from a
peasant mindset but a servant from the
place where you say i choose to leave
from behind
i choose to use my greatness and my
light to elevate you
i choose to own my life but hand it over
to anyone who might need it in the
moment
oh if you stay rooted in that
it's a daily thing so i recommend that
you find a daily regimen
that keeps you steeped in gratitude a
daily regimen that has you
own your greatness whether it's the
reminder of the things i've just said
write the mantras out post them on your
mirror and recite
them each day i live by mantras i live
by affirmations
i i designed and began to own who i was
as a woman
because i kept reminding myself daily
who i could become
and then one day i want to remind myself
and it stuck
i didn't need the reminder and so i
started reminding myself of something
else
and i kept doing that daily daily and
then one day i want to remind myself and
it stuck
and so remind yourself of the woman the
man you're becoming
write it down write the mantra down i'm
a servant leader grateful for service
i own my brilliance unapologetically i
walk in the room and light it up with a
natural glow
i share my light with others with grace
and ease
you can choose any of these mantras you
can have them all so many times
people um look at the habits that they
have such as procrastination
and ask why do i procrastinate well i
pose that question back to you
ask yourself what's the benefit because
there's a benefit that you're getting
out of it
so whether you believe that last minute
throws you inside of an
energy source because that's what i used
to think i just think oh
last minute i'm more creative well the
truth is you're not more creative last
minute the truth is
that when you wait to the last minute
you're increasing your stress level
um you're bringing down your joy you're
eliminating peace of mind
when you understand the cost
procrastination is a word and
and the challenge is that
procrastination is so universally
accepted
it's like fear and stress
like i'm so stressed out and it's become
such our norm that it's okay
well ask yourself the question what's
the price that i pay
because i believe any behavior that you
don't want any longer
the way that the catalyst to change is
recognizing the price
because we're high producers we can
still get it done
inside of procrastinating we can still
get it done but if you ever take a
moment to stop
and ask yourself and answer what's the
cost
of me procrastinating and you can do
that for everything but we're focused on
procrastination now
what's the cost of me procrastinating
let's go down that list
when you procrastinate it costs you
clear
organizational time because now you're
rushing when you procrastinate it costs
you peace of mind
when you procrastinate you're now thrown
in urgency
urgency increases your stress urgency is
known to increase your stress if you
live in urgency you literally are
two three times more likely to have a
heart attack i hear
not confirmed but that's what i heard so
if you live in this space of urgency all
the time because of a behavior
that you can modify think about it
how are we forward moving upperly mobile
how are we brilliant
and operating in something we can
control there's so many things that you
can't control
procrastination is something that you
can control patience
is that thing that you know all of us
want
[Music]
but we don't know how to get the
patients to get it
it's that it's that gift and that
character that's only developed in the
discomfort
of the act of patience itself you know
i'm going to share a couple of stories
with you because i have had
more bouts with being impatient
than anything to the point now that i
think one of the
one of the characters that's the most
developed in me
is the character of patience i recognize
that if not now
it will happen um but mine now does not
mean never
my now means when it's supposed to
happen and my job is to stay in action
you know i was sitting in the van
on my way to a good friend's house i was
sitting in the van with many other
teachers from the secret
way back in 2008 and many many things
were happening and a lot of success was
going on but i was still struggling
so on the outside i had notoriety i was
in the secret we had been on
oprah and so many things were happening
but on the inside personally
i was still trying to figure out how to
pay my car note i was still trying to
figure out how to
you know take care of my son while i'm
on the road i still had all these
challenges that really did not make me
feel like i was successful
and i felt like i couldn't work another
hour of the day
i couldn't put forth any more energy i
couldn't do anything else and i've been
doing it so
long i've been grinding so long you
might know what i
what that looks like i was sitting in a
van on my way to john gray's house
a minute from mars remember from venus a
good friend of mine and it was so many
of us
in the van and i remember looking over
at my friend
john assaraf and i asked i said john
why does it have to be so hard why do i
have why is it taking so long
i feel like i've been at this forever
and i don't see any results i'm tired
i'm exhausted i feel like i'm about to
lose
faith in this dream and john turned to
me and he said something
that just shifted everything for me and
i hope it does the same for you
he looked at me and he said lisa you
cannot plant your seeds
and reap your harvest in the same season
in that year when i was really broke and
i was really broken
i was working at la unified school
district
i was miserable i was miserable because
i wasn't
living in my dream i was just doing a
j.o.b
and then one day i said well what what
do i need to do i
i need to i need to buy my freedom
that's what i need to do i need to buy
my freedom
well i don't know about buying my
freedom i don't know about buying i
don't know about having
money saved up my family didn't have
money saved up
my mother used to tell me oh this money
is burning my pocket so i know two
things about money it's hot
and we can't keep it long we'd always
have one week when we had all the food
in the refrigerator and then one week
where we were
the refrigerator was empty right come on
come on some of you guys know about that
to this day
i spend so much money on groceries you
guys oh my god it's like i'm feeding
like a family of ten
because i'm so afraid of anybody ever
being at my house and being hungry
and so i i wrote a check to myself
jelani was three 110 dollars
i took it to the bank wells fargo
i started a new account
the next check i wrote 125
and just like the first check i put in
the memo line funding my dream
i wasn't even clear what the dream was
but i knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly
there's something here i'm not even
clear about it i don't know how clear
you are but i wasn't clear about it but
i knew there was a calling on my life
greater than working for la unified
school district and no disrespect to l.a
unified school drink it just wasn't my
destiny
i wrote another check in two weeks 146
dollars
funding my dream now i started mailing
the checks in because i didn't want to
see my balance
because i didn't want to go shopping
because i
you're going to repeat what you learned
right until you decide to not repeat
what you learned
so i mailed the check in and then i
wrote another check
and i wrote another check and every
check i wrote i made sure it was 5
more than the first check the net the
previous check i sold
my ultima i had a car note sold my
altitude bought a clunker
because it didn't have a car note now i
can write a bigger check
funding my dream i moved out of my three
bedroom three bed
three bath house and moved in became a
roommate with my friend who smoked
i put towels at the base of the door so
the smoke wouldn't come through the door
i was willing to be inconvenienced are
you
yes yes i'm just saying i'm just i'm
just showing you the story i just
the charge i just gave you i stopped
getting my hair done that was when i
started going natural
i stopped going out i stopped going out
dancing i stopped going out to dinners
my family didn't know what was going on
they thought oh my god you know it's la
she's on drugs but she's not losing
weight so maybe not i don't know what's
going on
i kept writing bigger checks to myself
900 900
i mailed it to wells fargo funding my
dream
eleven hundred dollars melded to wells
fargo
funding my dream i still wasn't clear
what the dream was i just knew i had one
and it was being born through me and i
needed to give it a chance
that's all i knew you don't have to see
2
000 feet in front of you just see 200
and run to the 200.
yes yes don't have to see it all three
and a half years later i'd written a
check to myself
every two weeks for three and a half
years
i didn't go out for three and a half
years i didn't go dancing i
didn't get my hair done i did get my
nails done for three and a half
years are you willing to be in
convenience
for your conviction i walk in
to wells fargo three and a half years
later
and i said hi god bless you hi
my name is lisa nichols she says oh my
gosh you're the fun of my dream lady
i was like yeah i guess i am
and all of a sudden all the tellers came
running around
the manager came they're like oh my god
okay oh my god we have been wondering
we all got the same question y'all know
what the question's right
what's your dream i was like
um
i'm not sure but i know that it includes
inspiring people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
get having to be willing to give
themselves a thousand second chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
i'm not sure what it's going to look
like but it's just going to help people
i said i came to check my balance i've
been
writing a few checks to you guys that
say yes you've been writing a lot
i said i just want to check my balances
you don't know your balance i said no
i got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home
because my mama said money burns her
pocket and i don't want it to burn my
pocket i wanted to pay for
my freedom i said i just came to see
what my balance was if i had enough to
fund my dream as it gets clearer
she wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me
i looked at it i said oh no my name is
lisa shantay nichols
and my social security number i said
that is not my money
and i am not taking that money because
you're probably gonna want it back
so just fix that error right now and
they looked at me
they said you really don't think that's
yours
i said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank
or ten thousand dollars in the bank
that's sixty two thousand five hundred
dollars
in the bank they said miss nichols and
everyone teared up
the manager teared up the tellers teared
up
they said miss nichols whatever your
dream is
i think you can fund it now i looked at
my son jelani
who now was five or six and i said
jelani
our lives are gonna be a little
different now baby
jelani said yeah
mommy can we can't we now
go to mcdonald's see for three years
i've been telling jelani i'll make you a
big mac
mama makes big macs better than
mcdonald's
and so it began with a hundred and ten
dollar check
so i don't know what yours is i don't
know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right yes yes and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the bet
the next best step this is the first
step and so i just stopped by to let you
know you're on the right path
and and as you ramp up as you ramp up
you're going to have questions you're
going to be afraid i do more things
afraid now than i do fearless
because the bigger you play the bigger
your breakdown
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one every single one
of my errors
has required me to call an attorney
[Laughter]
like they're just big because i'm
playing big
i'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here be
willing
to go to the edge and not just
lean over and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump and watch them
soar
and look through the windows and all the
people who are living great lives
don't just go to the edge and feel it
be willing to lean fill your heartbeat
feel it that lets you know you're alive
to let you know you're okay fear fuels
you
fear lets you know go get more
information fear let you know stay up a
little later and study
fear let you know get up a little
earlier fear let you know ask for help
fear is informing you it's not stopping
you it's just another emotion like love
and compassion
and gratitude we just made it paralyze
us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear i feel it
and i'm moving forward anyway i feel it
and i'm gonna love
anyway i feel it and i'm gonna invest in
me
anyway i feel it and i'm gonna show up
and play anyway
when you get connected with fear it
becomes your best friend
and when you stand on the edge
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap anyway we've been taught
how to serve others sometimes
to the detriment of our own selves
sometimes we serve others higher than we
serve ourselves
at times we feel more comfortable with
saying yes to other people and less
comfortable
saying yes to our own self-care so i ask
you
what is that about it's about the
opportunity to fall
madly in love with you
the way you love those around you to
fall madly
in love with your well-being to fall
madly in love with who you are when you
get
up from taking care of yourself you when
you rise from a nap or you
rise from um a spa day or when you
leave the gym to fall madly in love with
that level of excellence
and when you do what you'll do is give
to
everyone else around you a better
version of you
so often times we sacrifice our own
well-being because we're being what i
call the sacrificial martyr
and i know that was me i would serve
everybody else and everyone else would
go ah
i just don't have any time for lisa
well that's the story we tell
i actually didn't believe that i deserve
to have a day off i didn't believe that
i deserved to have a spa day
i didn't believe that i deserved to take
a long walk on the beach
something in me kept saying that i
hadn't done enough
i hadn't achieved enough i hadn't gotten
far enough so it actually had little to
do with the people around me that i was
blaming it on
or using as my out my
child my parents my family my community
it had to do with lisa giving lisa the
chance
to actually enjoy the journey
while still on it joan baez says that my
coach susie carter she
first shared this with me that joan baez
says
the antidote for despair is action
so i said how can i be in action i was
always looking to be an action
what else can i do what else can i do
what else can i do and then i go learn
what else can i do so to me there's a
very short line between learning and
doing
yes and if you haven't done anything
what you learned why are you getting
more
education you haven't even implied what
you like
i'm a hell of a coach now it's like
people who read a book they don't go
apply it they just want to read the next
book right
hi the book i read when i was in my
deepest darkest hour stephen covey seven
habits of highly effective people
changed my life because i got into
radical action behind it
i was like oh oh stephen covey talks
about
attending your own funeral doing a
visionary session where you attend your
own funeral and there are four people to
speak what will those four people say
about you
what kind of brother were you what kind
of friend were you what kind of social
change agent were you
what kind of neighbor were you man when
i did that exercise i was like
oh i'm a nice person but i i'm not
getting the
they're not they're not saying the
things about me that i want to be saying
right yes
i'm writing my eulogy right now amar i'm
writing my eulogy
i'm writing my i'm writing my legacy i'm
not just living for now
i'm living for the 40 year 40 years from
now story being told about me
i'm living for my grandchildren's
grandchildren's grandchildren's story
about who great-great-great-grandma was
and when you live for a lifetime
not just your life cycle but a lifetime
you live for the legacy i'm writing my
legacy now
you won't sweat the small stuff anymore
you won't get caught up in gossip
you won't get caught up in and living
inside worry you might worry
but worry does not have worry does not
have permission
to take up real estate in your body
worry is
chased by solution and strategy yes by
action yeah
and i always tell people listen i'll
have every emotion like everyone else
i'll have fear i have doubt i have
judgment but you cannot take up real
estate my body there's no lease options
to buy
in my mind don't lease option by my mind
and don't take up real estate i got
things to do i got i got changes to make
and i'm not a superhero
i'm not i'm an ordinary woman i'm an
ordinary woman
who chooses every day to make one more
extraordinary decision
acknowledge your community see when you
celebrate the people around you that
bring you joy
or that teach you some of the hardest
lessons that you need to learn
the iron that sharpens the iron the
celebrators that celebrate you
those who hold the space for you and
with you
pray for you honor you when you
celebrate and lift them up the whole
tide rises so i want you to find
six people in your community not out of
obligation
but truly out of choice they can be in
your circle
in your family and your business circle
and i want you to acknowledge them
for the contribution that they bring to
your life
what i love about acknowledgement is
that when you acknowledge
other people that actually makes you
happier
it's just this amazing gift of giving
and what i love is that most people
would rather get an acknowledgement from
you than a physical gift
that means they don't necessarily need
the perfume they don't need the sweater
they don't need the new iphone whatever
they want you to look at them in their
eyes and say
you bring value you bring value to my
life
i honor you i celebrate you i appreciate
you
take time to have a personal moment with
them where
you're just seeing them
the number one reason why people feel
sad and disconnected
is because they say they don't feel seen
so in this acknowledgement i want you to
look into their eyes
and acknowledge them for who they are
and
how they make your life better when you
raise the community around you the
entire tide rises
the energy rises the joy rises the
expectation rises and guess what
if you make this a part of your weekly
habits with them i didn't say daily
i didn't say monthly either and i
definitely didn't say annually
but if you make this a part of your
weekly find one thing
to acknowledge at least six people in
your community for each week one
you'll feel like you'll feel much more
excited but all of a sudden there's a
vibration
that happens because you've created it
there's this energy of let's go do this
because what gets celebrated gets
repeated you want someone to repeatedly
do something
wonderful and amazing in your life you
repeatedly acknowledge them from a
genuine place
man it's so powerful when you truly
marry yourself to the acknowledgement
process
to the practice of acknowledgement when
you get into the practice of
acknowledgement
all of a sudden people will mirror back
to you you don't acknowledge to get it
back you acknowledge because you want
people to be seen
but there's just this this dance that
begins to occur
that's absolutely delicious every
relationship is a relay
it's like my dad's played tennis for
over 40 years and
and i've attempted to play with him at
times and what i realized is that
relationships are like a tennis match i
hit the ball to you
you hit the ball back and a relationship
where you think it's only about one
person that's not tennis that's
racquetball
right but a relationship is a tennis
match and so if a relationship is
working
it's because of the way we both are
engaging
if it's truly working and if it's not
working
it's the way we both are engaging and so
there could be passive engagement and
there could be active engagement
so when you're not speaking up for what
you want when you're holding and you're
living with a bunch of withholds
that's engagement that's just the way
you're engaging
so so every relationship has two parts
whether your part is active
or your part is passive every
relationship
has engagement a level of engagement and
that engagement is on a different level
i wasn't supposed to be here by many
people's standard
i wasn't supposed to be here i wasn't
qualified to be here
see i was that woman on government's
assistance in 1994.
i was that woman on wic women infinite
children in 1994.
i was that woman that couldn't afford to
put pampers on my son so i wrapped him
in a towel for two days
in 1995. i'm that woman
so what would get me to being a
best-selling author times seven books
running a multi-million dollar company
having my company go public two years
ago
and going from welfare to wall street
it would simply be being non-negotiable
so i just stopped by
to check in if you're willing to be
non-negotiable
if you're willing to stop asking the
world for permission
to be amazing to be brilliant
to be divine stop asking the world for
permission
and begin today to give the world
notice yes yes see ajit says something's
gonna happen to you while you're here
and i love that have an expectation on
your life
you didn't come here for them to do you
okay i'm here do me
no this is your life your opportunity
you're brilliant
see the doors have been open and now you
dance to your rhythm
sing to your song you play to your tune
and all you need to do is pick up a
little bit here and pick up a little bit
there
and then take radical action and become
non-negotiable
abundant thinkers live in non-negotiable
average thinkers living optional
average thinkers of i really would love
to have a new business
but your behaviors are not congruent
with what you say you would love
when you move from optional to
non-negotiable you slid
you've slid every other option off the
table
i wasn't interviewed 155 times in five
months
and the number one question i was asked
was lisa how did you go from public
assistance to going public
how did you go from welfare to wall
street how did you build a multi-million
dollar business how did you do it
and i look i said i just slid every
other option off the table like i really
did i slid every other option
there was no other option burn the ship
burn the ships don't go back there was
no there was no other option
i didn't even i didn't have a plan b
it's a capital a or baby damn a
but it's a it's now or later but i'ma
get it
once you get to that place something
happens
the universe aligns with you because
you're so intentional
so many people ask me on so many
different platforms how do i find the
courage
too dot dot dot dot as if courage
is something outside of you you don't
look under the pillow
at home you don't look under your bed
you don't look in the glove compartment
of your car
and go find courage so let me just start
off with saying you don't find courage
you cannot find courage you choose
to not allow the fear to manage your
choices
so i know that sounds like that's just
like a oh won't want lisa but i'm going
to always tell you the truth
if i told you how to find something that
means that you don't have it already
i'm not going to tell you how to find
something that's not lost
the the reality is when you are more
consumed
with what other people's perception of
you than you are with your own truth
you will always feel like you're not
enough you will
always feel like you're not enough
because no matter how far you come no
matter how far you go
someone will always believe that there's
further that you can go which they're
true
it's truth so how do you
how do you manage or how do you uh
have the courage to have transformation
um
without getting consumed with other
people's thoughts of your perception of
you
you become more committed to your own
transformation than you are to managing
people's perception of your life
when i talk about celebrating the
journey
that's a that has many layers to it
celebrating the journey one means
don't wait until you've arrived
somewhere
to celebrate yourself that's number one
it means
that you're always going to be in
pursuit of something so don't wait to
arrive
to acknowledge yourself don't wait till
you arrive
arrive because i still haven't arrived
like
we don't arrive anywhere like if you are
waiting to arrive somewhere before you
celebrate you oh my god
it's going to be a long long life
celebrating yourself along the way
inside the journey it is it is
as big as allowing
others to celebrate your greatness how
many times do we minimize someone else's
um acknowledgement of us you know i hear
so many i used to do it all the time too
people say oh my god you're so great no
no
no no no no like you want them to run
past the compliment
like you feel uncomfortable well hold on
celebrating yourself along the way
inside the journey is allowing people to
acknowledge you
i like to set quarterly goals instead of
annual goals
i like to make them a bit more
bite-sized now i start with a big
bodacious scary hairy goal right
then i immediately release that goal and
chunk it down into four smaller goals
that are bite-sized digestible and
palatable
i can measure them every 90 days
you want to be able to measure write
this down you want to be able to measure
your actions your goals and your
milestones
every 90 days when you do that
it allows you to see how close on path
you are have you exceeded your own
expectation
if you have a goal that this year i want
to make an additional forty five
thousand dollars or i will make an
additional hundred thousand dollars
and you get to the first quarter and
you're thirty thousand dollars in you
know you're on
path however if you have the goal over
the year i want to make an additional
hundred thousand dollars
and you get to the end of the first
quarter and you're at ten thousand
dollars
in additional revenue you know you need
to do something
you know you need to ramp up or you know
that this next season this next time
i need to make sure that i'm doubling up
on my revenue to hit that goal
versus getting to november and realizing
that you're only at thirty five thousand
dollars
towards your hundred thousand dollar
additional revenue goal whatever your
goal is whether it's a hundred thousand
or whether it's ten thousand or whether
it's a million dollars
in addition or whether it's new
relationships or whether it's a social
media
so many times we've become so dutiful
working
and being diligent and being responsible
and being on point
that we forgot to do the things that
bring us joy
you know i as i was developing my
business
i thought i was doing the thing that i
loved the most which was transforming
lives and
talking to teens inspiring teens
inspiring adults
but i forgot that i love to dance i
forgot that i love to hang out
i forgot that i loved a date i forgot
about so many things
so i traded one love for all these other
little things and i was being
responsible as a mom responsible as a
business owner responsible as a daughter
and yet my norm had become filled with
all the dutiful things in my life and
not the things that necessarily brought
me
the most joy while my family brings me
great joy my work
brings me great joy there was a part of
me that was slowly dying away
just because it was unfed so let's make
a list of what do you love to do
what do you love to do and then let's
set an intention
that don't try to do it all the time i
think we go to the extremes once a week
i'm gonna do this
or you can't go from zero to once a week
but start from zero from once a month
and so your norm is whatever you decided
to be you are the designer of your
destiny
and you are the author of your
autobiography and no one can write your
story but you
life isn't happening to you you're
co-creating you are the main character
you you wrote the screenplay this is
your life
and how you look at it and the lenses
that you look at your life through has
everything to do with how much you enjoy
it or not
so often you don't move forward because
you're keeping such
score from what didn't work in the past
you are
holding yourself hostage to 1997 to
2005.
you're holding yourself hostage uh in
love
to that past relationship that didn't
work or you're holding yourself in
hostage
in business to the money that you may
have
thought you wasted or the deal that went
bad and so
one of the ways that i give myself
permission
for two on two levels permission to have
lived a life that has some beautiful
experiences
and some really tangy lessons i mean
they're spicy
they hurt they're painful when i give
myself permission to have had that
i also give myself permission to keep
leaping give myself permission to keep
dreaming
give myself permission to keep learning
how to get it right
learning how to love the unlovable
forgive what seems to be the
unforgivable
to leap again even while i still have a
bandage on my chin
from the last time i failed so i want to
invite you if you fall
fall catch your breath put a bandage on
it whether you fail financially
you fail physically with health and
wellness you fail
spiritually you fell emotionally you
felt in a relationship
okay a part of flying is understanding
what
the distinction between flying and
falling and the only way you understand
the distinction
is that you experience full life when
you experience full life
it's like this life isn't just flat line
it's not just like this
you make your heights feel better
because you understand
this was a failure and and what i mean
by failures
this taught me a lesson this stung this
every single
failure has a lesson in it to me a
failure is a lesson wrapped in
and and some sticky icky paper that
stung that hurt
and so give yourself permission give
yourself permission
to play big to be nervous
to fall down to sit down for a minute
just don't take up real estate in the
sitting down
don't take up real estate in the
analyzing don't take
don't take up real estate in the
preparation you've been getting prepared
for a
long time for something trust that
you'll either fly if you leap right now
or your fall if you leave right now and
if you fly you'll understand what
soaring feels like and if you fall
you'll understand what getting up feels
like
either way you're okay that's how i play
big
with my knees knocking that's how i play
big even
when there's something in my in my
consciousness reminding me of the last
time i did something like this
and it didn't quite work out and i still
play big
because i gave myself i give myself i
constantly give myself permission
to totally win and soar or totally fall
and get up
and that way there's nothing to truly be
afraid of
remember this is a dialogue
not a monologue which means we're in a
dynamic conversation versus me just
entertaining
you i work with thousands hundreds of
thousands of people
and trust is always at the top of the
list
coach show me how to trust again coach
what happens when i've been betrayed
coach show me how to trust myself again
trust is a gift and when our trust is
violated
by any form we feel like a little bit of
it's been chipped away
but here's what i want to let you know
trust is something that can be restored
and trust is something that people can
earn and trust is something that you
have enough of
it always hurts my heart when i hear
someone say i don't trust
i don't trust because what i know is
you're not trusting your future
something or someone in your future
because of something that happened in
your past
and in so many ways you're making your
next pay for your ex
you're making your future pay for your
past you're making that
unexperienced moment pay for that
past experience who more
deserves to be loved and honored and
celebrated to full capacity
than you and if you don't stick your
feet
fully in then you can't fully feel
submerged in the possibility
is there a chance that this person that
you're in this relationship with now
this friendship with now this business
appointment with now this this community
relationship
is there a chance that they may not play
full out and honor you yes
but here's what i know you don't want to
do you don't want to have a life of
saying i played halfway i stuck my toe
in instead of jumping in
so you want to do your due diligence one
of the things i learned
from my years of living trusting
being betrayed hurting crying
praying laughing getting back up
and being committed to love again trust
again
was that any time that i felt betrayed
anytime that i felt like someone didn't
honor me
there was a part that i played in that
experience
there was a better question that i could
have asked sooner
there was a clear line that i could have
drawn way deeper
in the sand there was a notice of
intuition or there was a tap on the
shoulder that
uh i was the alarm clock was going off
there was something that i could have
seen said
or done that i was a viable part of this
equation
now i own the part that's mine and i own
the part that's not mine but
how i bring that forward and how i
recommend you bring it forward is
ask better questions now you're not the
same person you were three years ago
five years ago ten years ago
you're not the same person you were last
year ask
a better question and you'll get a
better answer
it began to shift from me when i moved
from optional
to non-negotiable when i moved from i
really really
want this to hold on this is
non-negotiable
it's time for me to move from i'd like
it to happen
to no matter what it has to happen
no matter what jilani has to have the
type of opportunities
that normally an african-american male
child from south central l.a
whose father went to prison when he was
eight months old wouldn't have
see i had to become non-negotiable
that jelani has a breathtaking future i
had to become non-negotiable and say no
matter what
that i was gonna get off government's
assistance and not only was i going to
get off government's assistance
that i was going to create a healthy
lifestyle around money
finances and fiscal success and
responsibility
i had to say no matter what around
creating the life that i love
where i can travel the world and inspire
people i had to say no matter what
around keeping my family intact and keep
my relationships intact
while i did that i had to say no matter
what
around my health and my wellness and
bringing back
physical prosperity to my life and to my
body
nothing happened until i went from
optional to non-negotiable
to no matter what when i came to no
matter what that's when the mountain
if it was in front of me it had to bow
down and have to move and so
i believe that you're in the exact same
place
that as you move into next year you're
out of no matter what time
you're at a non-negotiable time you're
at a move every other option
off the table so many people look at
uh fear or even doubt but they look at
fear as if it's
the emotional enemy you know it's the
enemy emotion like oh i can deal with
compassion i can deal with love
i can do it understanding but when fear
comes oh my god bad thing no
first of all change your relationship to
fear i've said this before
fear is not the enemy the feeling of
fear is just like any other emotion
fear is actually informing you fear is
telling you that you need to do
something
either do more research get some support
get some insight study a little more
slow
down fear is actually feeding you so
then ask yourself the question
what do i need to do think or go get
to dissipate this fear because remember
fear
is fear becomes present when you've made
up something that
could happen in the future and it makes
you afraid right now like oh my god i'm
afraid i can get hurt in this
relationship
oh my god i'm afraid i'm losing my money
you're just projecting a story that you
made up
then back into that fear and go okay
wait
then what do i need to do to minimize
the fear
that i might get hurt what do i need to
do to minimize the fear that i might
lose my money what do i need to do
of course you can't 100 eliminate
the possibility but you can greatly
reduce the chances
by asking what am i afraid of what am i
afraid that's going to happen
and then secondly recognize that
fear doesn't mean stop people think oh
i'm afraid let me stop okay that's a
choice to stop
fear doesn't necessarily mean stop fear
might mean proceed with caution
or proceed with more strategy
fear doesn't whenever i'm feeling fear
it doesn't tell me this i don't even
think now to stop with the fear
i do think to slow down go get some help
go get some insight voice my fear
so that it's not just all in my head
recognize that fear
is going to come in when you're playing
bigger than you've ever played before
i i say if your knees aren't knocking
and your teeth aren't chattering just a
little at least
then you're not playing big enough the
bigger you play the more you're gonna
feel your knees knock and you're gonna
hear your teeth chatter
and i'm always playing big i'm always
feeling my knees
knock and i'm always hearing my teeth
chatter
but i've created a relationship with
that fear to go
hold on let's say fear is right here
fear what are you telling me
because fear really is
it's it's a story it's
it's something you think could happen
and could it happen yeah
but could it not happen yeah
so don't try to outrun
fear don't try to outrun doubt and
definitely
don't wait until doubt and fear are gone
before you move
find out what doubt and fear needs
to dissipate into the nothingness that
it always was
what does it need and then
understand that action brings clarity so
the more you move forward the more
action you're in
the more clarity you get because action
breeds clarity
and clarity comes with action so many
times you're sitting on the sideline
waiting
waiting to get completely clear before
you take any action
and clarity is waiting for you to get an
action to create clarity
so be willing be willing
to play full out a little nervous
i remember there was a time in my life
when all i wanted
was for people to accept me but i
realized
that i needed them to accept me and love
me
because i wasn't really accepting lisa
i wasn't really loving lisa to my
fullest
so while today i don't invite you to not
care
if people reject you i am inviting you
to if you fully love and show up for you
first then you're less impacted you're
less
disrupted when someone doesn't embrace
you the way
you believe you should be embraced see i
realize that
we're we are iron for others iron
sharpens iron
we're also triggers for others there's a
thousand reasons
why someone might reject you my
grandmother says man's rejection
is god's protection so not everyone
that's in your space should be in your
space
and sometimes people have to opt out
on your behalf to help you out how many
times
have you been in a friendship or
relationship and it
ended and maybe not immediately after it
ended
but somewhere in the next 30 60
90 days a year maybe two years you took
a deep breath
i actually feel more relief that that
relationship has transitioned whether
it's a relationship with a job
a friend an ex whatever
so while we don't want to have rejection
in our life
i say all rejection isn't bad and
sometimes it's not rejection
it's simply transition it's simply
completion
you know i realized that i wanted
everyone to love me
but when i begin to love lisa i stop
having to manage or having the desire to
manage how other people like me
your job is to wake up each day and like
you
now i get kicked out of college i got
kicked out of college
my second year because i didn't want to
continue to run track i took my team
undefeated the first year
wow and they went from ha not having won
a track meet in two years at all
to going undefeated into in one year and
you could attribute what allowed you to
lead the team to do that in one or two
insights what would it be i had
unwavering confidence
did you cultivate that or was it natural
was it cultivated at home or was it
personally cultivated
my dad and my mom they they i don't know
if it was brainwashed or encouraged me i
could do anything
like they they i wasn't opposition
didn't scare me it never have scared me
like i don't look at how
how big the mountain is if i can climb
it i go are we gonna climb it
and what do we need to climb that size
mountain you don't measure if i can do
something based on the size of the
opposition
you decide we're going to do it and then
decide what to do for that particular
scenario
i made the best decision i could based
on what i knew in that moment
and when i know more i'll do more when i
know better i do better
and i'm going to love me in every moment
when i look back at the decisions i made
10 years ago some of the people i dated
some of the money i spent and what i
spent money on
some of the places i went i go what was
i thinking
and the answer is i was i made decisions
based on what i knew at that time
i'm outside now and you can hear the
gardeners in the background they're
cutting away
trees they're cutting away dead limbs
they're cutting away
old grass they're they're they're um
they're mining the weeds and pulling
things out
just like we should do in our lives and
some of those things that we should take
away
are the the fear of people's thoughts of
us
and what those thoughts are going to
show up as in our lives
listen what i know i love the sound of
all the machinery in the background
because that reminds me to trim away
to cut away allows a space for new
things to grow
so sometimes you have to cut away the
need to be
liked by everybody the need to manage
everyone else's perceptions and thoughts
of you you have to cut it away like
those gardeners
are cutting away dead leaves like those
gardeners are cutting away
the weeds the things that grow in
between the beautiful grass and between
the beautiful flowers
the things growing up inside that's
what's happening in the middle of your
transformation
other people's thoughts other people's
inconvenience people want to hold
people want to hold you hostage to the
person they've always known you to be
who what are these new thoughts you have
what are these little things you're
doing we don't know you this way
go back to the old you no be more
committed to the you that you're
becoming
than you are to the you that they're
familiar with over the years i've had to
learn
how to disconnect myself from people
how to pull away how to move on without
what i call
benihana in people now i don't know if
you remember but
if you ever go to a benihana restaurant
they have those
sharp knives and they kind of go and you
don't even know that the zucchini is
like all diced up until they move it and
then
everything is cut apart well i used to
have a habit of like cutting people off
so well
so fast that i felt like i benny haunted
them like they didn't know they were
like all sliced and diced until they
went to walk away and their hair fell
off
and then their arms fell off and i over
the years i had to learn
how do i complete by the way
i would say don't break
up with people don't break away from
people
don't stop being their friends
a better mindset is recognize when the
relationship
is just complete now i say complete say
complete with me when i say complete
that means the relationship
has had every experience that it needs
to have
you've done everything you need to do
and it's just complete
so you don't have to make people wrong
that was a big lesson for me because
we're taught
that in order for relationships to end
someone's brains
need to be splattered on the ceiling
well
the older wiser me recognizes that i can
end
relationships from people who i've
outgrown or people who might be toxic or
people who are just not a fit for me
and also leave their dignity
intact keyword i want you to write that
down
type that in chat because there is a way
that you can complete with people notice
i'm using these keywords with you
you can complete with people meaning
every experience that we need to have
we've had
and now i'm complete
that you can do that and leave their
dignity intact
you can say this relationship has run
its course
you don't have to outline everything
that's not working because you know we
outline things that are not working
all we're doing is making people wrong
so let me just say
the way you complete a relationship is
to first
check your ego because your ego our
ladies
your she-go they will get in the way and
what you want to do is point-point
point-point point
i'm i'm done with you because of this
this
and this and we all know when you point
one finger over there the three fingers
point back at you we've all heard it i
begin to become an explorer of what i
don't know
i want to read books i'd never read i
want to hang around people that i'd
never hang around
i want to know what they know i want to
have discussions about things i never
talked about
i wanted to feed my brain something that
my brain didn't know
so that my brain can tell my body to do
something it never done
so then when my brain feeds my body and
my body feeds my life
then i begin to have an experience that
i've never had before
it wasn't rocket science people want to
make success
rocket science success is not rocket
science
you go and find the thing that you don't
know learn the thing you don't know
and do the thing you haven't been doing
and get the life you say you want
i just all i wanted was unfamiliar
but you have to understand that most
people don't invite in unfamiliar
because
people are more committed hold on
people are more committed to a familiar
discomfort
than they are to an unfamiliar new
possibility
the key words are familiar and
unfamiliar see we want to have a new
experience
while having some of the same behaviors
because they're familiar to us yeah
they're comfortable
they're they're familiar some of them
not even comfortable people in
relationships are not even comfortable
it's just familiar people are still at
jobs that aren't even comfortable
they're just familiar so that's the
crazy is that we are more committed to a
familiar discomfort
than we are to an unfamiliar new
possibility because of the familiarity
not even the comfort i became
i became comfortable living in
the discomfort of the unknown instead of
making
big macro goals you know those big
bodacious goals
make some micro goals smaller goals i
don't make an annual goal
i make quarterly goals i make monthly
goals
and each quarter and each month the goal
that i hit
i stop and celebrate myself now i
celebrate myself by
making me something really good and
inviting one person over or three people
over and say i'm celebrating myself
for small microwaves taking myself
out for a nice night something to eat or
just sharing with a friend
i celebrating yourself along the journey
is also not keeping your wins
a secret huh i used to keep my victories
a secret
i would get an award or i would close a
deal or i would get a new contract or i
would whatever
and no one knew because i didn't want to
brag
well what if i i know i'm not a bragger
like what if you know you're not a
bragger
can you not be someone who brags but
is someone who wants to celebrate
yourself along the journey
we're all like little three-year-old
kids what gets celebrated gets repeated
and if you want to repeat successful
behaviors then you got to celebrate them
because what's celebrated gets repeated
we're just kids
unconsciously we have a tendency to
do things to influence someone's
perception of us
and really what we're trying to do is
change our control ah
that word again we're trying to control
their perception of us
because we feel like they're being
judged so we get into the proving
business i said in another
lisa nichols episode that you have
nothing to prove nothing to protect
nothing to hide and nothing to defend
that's not just a mouthful of words that
is literally
a lifetime of disconnecting
from the need to prove to someone you're
smart enough you're kind enough you're
loving enough you're worthy enough
you're
enough dot dot dot right
and i remember for years because i
didn't graduate from college
i was always trying to prove i was smart
enough always
and then i had a son without being
married so then i wanted to prove that i
was godly enough
i was always trying to prove something
until it just became
so exhausting what i was doing
was trying to control people's judgment
of me
procrastination is really putting off
your own desires procrastination
is putting yourself last procrastination
shows up when we are so used to putting
everyone else in front of us
or we're actually afraid to do that
thing that we say we want to do because
we're not sure
we can handle the outcome but the whole
attachment to procrastination and
self-love
what you can do tomorrow why not do
today
what you can do today why not do right
now
you know one of my team members talked
about reading a book called touch it
once
which means if you can touch it once and
get it done how much more productive
will you be
what happens when you feel like you're
always being judged
number one is divorce yourself
from trying to manage someone's judgment
of you i know that sounds backwards
because we want to go over there and
change them i know well when i figure
that one out you'll be the first
to know but in the meantime how can you
separate yourself divorce i know it's a
strong word but that's the separation
from the need to monitor
other people's judgment of you let me
tell you what that answer is
you go over to self-awareness you go
over to recognizing
i am whole i am smart enough
i am wise enough i am kind enough
not from a bragging way not from a
self-righteous way
from the most humble way possible can
you wake up
tomorrow morning and be content with who
you are
irregardless of anyone's opinion of you
once you leave the house or maybe the
person next to you or the people
downstairs the people in your same house
can you wake up tomorrow standing and
living in
the statement and the knowing i am
enough and then leave everyone's opinion
to them
we train people how to treat us in 2007
when i was on the oprah show
it was the thing that came up and out of
me and she was like yes
it was that thing that said we train
people how to treat us
like they're looking at how we're what
we're saying yes to
and what we're co-signing on and if
we're the yes woman or the yes man all
the time
then one our yes isn't as valuable
because everyone automatically expects
it because we give it away all the time
and two they're gonna keep asking
because they know we're gonna get that
they're gonna get yes
and if you're a producer and deliverer
you're the one i'm gonna come to all the
time because you're producer and
delivery you're gonna get the job done
even to the detriment of your own joy
even to the detriment of your own
happiness
but again you train people how to treat
you
but the good news about training someone
is that they can be retrained now did
you consciously sit down and say i want
to manifest
inspiring millions of people making
millions of dollars was it
was it a conscious thing were there
moments where you sat there when you
weren't living in that reality
where you said you know what i'm going
to decide i'm going to figure it out i
might not know how i don't know
where or what but i'm going to commit to
it and make it a reality i mean
talk to me at the core of your
experience right so i love how you say
millions of dollars i said i want to
inspire people
and i want to be able to pay my bills
that was initially
i want to i want to have a i want to run
out of month
before i run out of money big
i want to have enough that like you
can't think about having abundance until
you
you literally give yourself permission
to have enough yeah get past scarcity
today
like so i want to have enough to dream
and so
my first i have i think i have a
ministry mindset my first i just want to
help people
i want to help people who and i want to
i want to be rewarded for my efforts
right and then once i got past that i
said okay
i want more i i want to generate
millions i want to serve millions
inspire millions and generate millions i
think i deserve all of that
but that had to do with my self-worth
right i had to feel worthy
to touch millions and i had to feel
worthy
to touch millions i had to feel worthy
of both
and so that was personal development
which is why i live and i stay in
personal development
i teach personal development i teach
wealth development i teach business
development and i teach personal
development
because you have to have both practice
active
yes i'ma say it again underline circle
active practice
active self-care that's where you
identified
what rejuvenates you and made plans
to make time for self-care during the
busy season
so you made a list of what you know
rejuvenates your soul your mind your
body your spirit
from walking on the beach to reading a
book to taking down time
free things and retreats or a spa
whatever it is
that rejuvenates your soul to make a
list of it
and then to make plans active
self-care to do those things during your
busy season
if you find that the relationships
around you have
toxic outcomes then i want you to look
at where is the breakdown
is the breakdown in communication is the
breakdown in
how you communicate the words you're
using is the breakdown in who you choose
to be around
is the breakdown in the engagement of
what you're talking about
what i've learned is that if you're not
talking about things that are high
enough
and big enough things that are inspiring
enough
you will slip into the smallness every
single time
if you don't choose an intentionally
high evolving
encouraging conversation you will slip
into the cracks
you will slip into those crevices of
smallness
and petty and until you get people
trained
that you're going to live up here
without telling i need you to know
it's not an announcement it's a way of
being and so what do you choose to
participate in
it's a stepping over your desire to hear
smallness
gossip negative feedback it's when
someone is engaging in negative feedback
about
someone else the fact that you didn't
add anything to the conversation doesn't
let you off the hook
did you stop the conversation did you
say hold on
i don't want to engage in speaking
negatively with them at all why don't
you have a conversation with them
it's course correcting behaviors in your
space
at the risk at the risk of losing the
relationship
but what you basically do is is you say
here's where i play
here is where i live i'm not visiting
this high road of integrity
i'm not visiting this high road of
conscious thinking and
awareness and respect and humility and
and honoring the dignity and people i
don't visit this place
i live here i don't visit this place
i live here and in a loving way
anyone that's engaging with you has two
choices
they either engage with you here or they
choose to engage with someone else
now if you find that you're going down
to be in the relationship or you're
going down and you're taking and you're
the person taking the relationship down
because you're in a moment of anger or
you're in a moment of resentment
or you're in a moment of hurt then
you're not living in your highest
integrity you just visit every now and
again when you come to this channel
uh-oh i see my my my shantae coming out
right now
shantae is my middle name it's what i do
when i start getting real edgy because i
really want you to get it
so you need to make a decision on where
you choose to reside
and then you don't leave your conscious
neighborhood
to go visit other people's neighborhood
if it's not as high as yours
people will rise to the occasion or
they'll choose not to rise
and they'll pick other people to be with
and hang with and i know that sounds
easier said than done because some of
the people who are playing at a lower
level might be in family
it might be and that's fine too you can
love people
it doesn't mean you have to spend tons
and tons and tons of time if that time
costs you something spend as much time
as you can
spend as much time as serves you spend
as much time as they
will allow you to spend but never leave
this place
even if being with them causes you to to
allow them to be where they are
you don't have to engage in that so the
bottom line
and supporting you to either recognize
are you the toxic element
are you surrounding yourself in toxic
element is to make a commitment where
you live
where am i living and first own where
you're currently living because if you
own it you might go you know what i do
slip into that small but it's okay own
it
that's conscious awareness that's
powerful
own it and then go where do i want to be
and then what's the distance between
here and there and what do i have to do
to get there
what i have to say no to do i have to
participate in
what i have to ask forgiveness for what
i have to clean up what relationships
require
cleaning up and then what declarations
must i make
celebrate your wins this is where i
invited you to make a list of the 10
things
that you have to celebrate about this
past year now
if you're just joining me then it's not
too late
make a list you've done many more than
10 things
but make a list of 10 things that you
have to celebrate about
over this past year and they can cover
any area
from family to finances to business to
health and wellness to relationships
to body to fitness anything so let me
first
explain to you what forgiveness isn't
because
most people won't forgive because they
have an incorrect understanding of what
forgiveness is
so forgiveness is not pardoning
someone's behavior
it's not excusing someone's behavior
forgiveness
isn't admitting that you were wrong
forgiveness
isn't saying what was done to me is okay
forgiveness isn't any of those things
i'll try
says i'll make a feeble attempt i will
is
absolute non-negotiable no matter what
there's a certain
energy that goes forth when you say i'll
try
and there's a different energy that goes
forth when you say i will
when you make the declaration of i will
that says mountain
if you are there you must move
i'll try says i hope i got enough energy
to make it up or around the mountain and
if not i'ma sit at the bottom of the
hill
when you fail to make a plan okay well
hold on
this might hit you between the eyes you
know i love you but when you fail to
make a clear
concrete plan that has goals and
milestones meaning there are smaller
goals
that you can hit to get to the bigger
goal and has a by
wind date not in february not in
august but august 15th
by 5 p.m eastern standard time yeah when
i set a goal i even want to know the
time zone and have it done by
clarity when you fail to make a plan
with clear distinction
when you fail to make a clear plan you
have clearly planned to fail
i'll say it again when you fail to make
a clear plan
then you clearly plan to fail i know
that hits you hard
i've done it many times i have clearly
planned to fail many times
because i had an idea and it was just in
my unconscious i didn't know
now i want to bring to you what i know
to you so you know it
i want you to make a clear plan when you
create a clear plan
then you're clearly planning to succeed
your belief systems were handed to you
by your parents
and by your grandparents and they were
pretty much embedded by the time you
were 10 years old
so there's some beliefs that you didn't
even have a chance to develop for your
own you just
are living them out you inherited them
you inherit the beliefs and didn't
unconsciously inherited them
and so the good news is you get to
choose to the belief systems you like
and then you get to divorce i'm going to
say divorce because that's a strong word
we all know what separation looks like
when you say divorce
you get to divorce from a belief system
that doesn't serve you any longer
a belief system that says money is the
root of all evil maybe
or a belief system that says only rich
people uh have money
or all rich people are are are uh crooks
or i you said my belief system used to
be that wealthy people aren't spiritual
that if i'm wealthy i can't be a
spiritual person you have to pick god or
money one or the other i gotta
pick my faith or my finances i can't
have both that's a belief system
and and i invite you to divorce it
because it's not the case i have both
and i live in both quite well i use my
money for good in the world
and the more the more money you have the
more good you'll do if you're a good
person
so money makes you more of who you are
so you will only be more of who you are
with money
when we talk about setting healthy
boundaries again and i know it sounds as
if i keep going back to the same thing
but
setting healthy boundaries is not about
you keeping other people out
if someone crosses your line in the sand
it's because you never made your line
deep enough
no one can ever go further with you than
you've given them permission to go
so as hard and as difficult as it is to
hear
because this was hard for me to hear
when i had to admit it to myself
that the way people treated me was based
on how i trained them to treat me
so i have to say it to you you've
trained people to treat you the way
they're treating you
so if people are crossing your
boundaries because they didn't know it
was there
if people call you odd hours a night
it's because you keep answering
if people ask you to do beyond what
you're able to do it's because you keep
saying yes
if people don't ever think you need rest
it's because you act like you don't need
rest
i know this is not probably what you
want to hear but i signed up and you
signed up
in this relationship to give you what
you need to hear not necessarily what's
always easy to hear
and i'm only telling you what i needed
to hear myself i'm only telling you
the lesson that i had to learn that we
train people how to treat us
i have this program where i look at your
money blueprint and i help you look at
your money blueprint
and and i ask you questions how is money
in your household
that was it uh the source of argument
the source of
contention and divisiveness because if
so
you don't want money to divide you in
your family so you might not want to
have money around or you want too much
because you don't want to be divided
judged or whatever did it keep your
parents away like what was the what was
your relationship to money as a child
because that's fueling you that has an
unconscious
um influence over you filter of how you
see everything exactly you want to bring
from the unconscious to the conscious
you might not be listening to it but you
definitely don't want to have any
unconscious power over you so that's
number one
be aware of your money blueprint how is
money related to in your community
how is it related to in your house um
what what did you think about money
how's your faith attached to it
i used to think that literally in order
to be like sister brown
who was like the most godly woman in my
church when i was a teenager she was
amazing
but we also had fundraisers for sister
brown
that i could not have a million dollars
in my bank account and be sister brown
yeah so i had to re it took me years to
do that setting
quarterly goals to recognize that goals
that are going to be hit
are goals that are bite-sized digestible
and
palatable and you can measure them every
90 days
we together discovered that 90 day goals
allows us to get to annual goals and
two-year goals and five-year goals but
90-day goals allows you to have
bite-sized palatable
digestible goals that could be measured
and or adjusted
every 90 days oh my god i love this
question
i don't think i've ever been asked this
question before i've never had the
opportunity to
explain it being the best version of you
first of all it's not don't think of it
holistic
i want you to break it down to different
parts of your life
because when you are committed to being
the best version of you
which in summary it's the you that
you're so
incredibly proud of holistically it's a
360 approach it says i'm not
perfect so best does not mean the
perfect version of you
because i think perfection and balance
are two
illusions that are designed to help you
keep chasing something that's not even
attainable
so perfect is not attainable and balance
is not attainable
so it's perfectly managing my
imperfection
and releasing balance and having harmony
number one
but the best version of you is really
saying that in each area of my life
i'm in movement in each area of my life
i'm an evolution
in each area of my life i'm active i am
actively participating in an upwardly
way
in an upwardly mobile way in this area
of my life
times every area of my life it doesn't
necessarily mean that
you're always where you want to be but
it does mean that you're being
responsible
you're being active and you're being
proactive finances
that you're looking at your numbers just
this morning
just this morning i ran my credit score
again
i want to see what's on it i want to be
actively participating in my financial
growth
i looked at my savings i looked at my
life insurance i just looked at my
my long-term plan not necessarily
because i want to buy
another house or i want to buy a car i
just want to be on top of it
i want to be responsible for it and then
health and wellness
just yesterday i was talking to matt and
going matt
it's time for us to do another health
and wellness campaign
i don't necessarily want to do it and it
slightly to moderately scares me a bit
when i'm bringing my
fitness into a public conversation but i
know
the responsible me the best version of
lisa
is saying hold me accountable hold me
accountable to my fitness goals hold me
accountable to my total wellness goals
and then last week i was just sitting
with someone saying you know what i need
to go down the list of all the checkups
that i've had
i need to make sure i'm not missing
anything relationships
i just said to a girlfriend yesterday
hold me accountable
hold me accountable to not running
i realize that i run well and i run
smoothly i run like a gazelle sometimes
when it comes to relationships you don't
it doesn't even look like i'm running
because i'm so busy
so i ask someone who knows me who knows
the love that i
want who knows my sexy excuses
i need you to hold me accountable when i
say this i want you to question it
and so while there's so much growth in
every area of my life
i'm being the best version that i know
to be because i'm active in every single
area i'm not saying i'm being the best
i am the best please don't get me wrong
with that
i'm just saying to be the best version
of myself so when you look at being the
best version of yourself
look at each part of your life and go
what am i actively doing
where you feel like i'm in the game and
it's there i'm not resigned
and i'm not praying for it to go right
or i'm not
in resignation and then complaint about
it i'm not a victim to that relationship
i'm not a victim to my finances
i'm not a victim to the relationships in
my family i'm an active part of creating
what's occurring
and it can always get better but i'm an
active part that's
being the best version of you and waking
up each morning and saying i
like me today i got many things i can
work on
but i like me today before you ever go
out on facebook or any other social
media platform
to check to see if anyone else like you
your job is to like you first
and every other like is bonus that's
stepping into the best
version of you setting long-term goals
that make your knees knock a little bit
and make your teeth chatter a little bit
those goals that you don't know
exactly how you gonna get it done but
it's something that you want to get done
it doesn't it stretches you but it
doesn't stress
you your goals are supposed to stretch
you
not stress you those things that
combination
and when you live in that capacity and
you focus and you operate in that one
that's when you're living in being the
best
version of you so when you look at being
your own rescue
what does that look like being your own
rescue comes from so many different
areas i've always taught that we need to
separate our
our life into categories and manage your
whole life
in categories the health and wellness
category what does being your own rescue
look like in health and wellness
for me it was pretty radical for me
it was all the way from not only getting
more physically fit
but it was going to the doctor and
asking for medical help
it was saying something's happening in
my body and i don't know what it was no
longer
ignoring what was happening what does
being your own rescue look like in your
finances
for me it was me writing myself a check
the way i wrote
sdng and the way i wrote the electricity
bill and the way i wrote
my rent check way back 20 years ago it
was me writing a check to my dream
and putting in the subject line funding
my dream
that was being my own rescue as well
what does being your own rescue look
like
in a relationship does it look like just
speaking up and
asking for what you need or does it look
like telling someone
i love you more often or thank you more
often
or please accept my apology for not
showing up for you what does being your
own rescue look like
in the different categories and then
what does
action look like to be that rescue
because when you can be your own rescue
you actually are your own superhero you
actually
are your own best friend you actually
become everything you need for you
and then you can serve everyone else
from your overflow
if you don't treat money right and
you're not responsible with money
money you will repel money because
you're not a good steward of it
and so until i became a better steward
of money and i'm still growing in that
area
and money didn't money and i we had a i
would keep giving it away
until it was all gone because my mindset
said it all had to be gone
there's never going to be extra yeah my
grandmother would make 10 dimes go in 20
different directions who was i to have
20 dimes in only 10 directions
needed yes right again mindset right
i love to go back and share some of my
favorite memories with you
my fondest and what i realized they're
actually my most
moving memories one happened
over 12 years ago i was in toronto
canada with margaret
and this gentleman walked up to me
standing about
six foot two caucasian man
in his mid-40s and he looked at me and
he goes lisa
[Music]
i have a problem with you i said you do
and my heart starts to beat i'm like oh
my god someone doesn't like me
what did i say wrong in their eyes and
what how is this gonna
play out and he goes i have a problem
i really have a problem and i said okay
how can i help you
he said i'm an atheist i don't believe
in god
i'm fine not believing in god i'm
comfortable i prefer not to believe in
god
i don't believe that there's a god and i
said okay
what's your problem he said my problem
is
i love you i love everything about you
i love the energy you come with i love
the way you speak i love what i feel
when i'm listening to you talk
he said and you keep referring to this
god
as your source and i don't believe in
god
so that's my problem and i said sir i'm
sorry
i'm not sure where your problem lies
i said if if you don't believe in god
you have that right
if you love me i'm excited because you
can feel that i love you too
and he looked at me and goes so let me
get this straight
this is not the part where you try to
convert me
or try to tell me how wrong i am or you
try to explain to me about your god so
that i can begin to believe
like you believe this is this not that
part you're not gonna do that
and i looked up at him i said why would
i do that
you're committed to whatever you believe
and my job is to honor your belief
system and it goes see
you're doing that thing again that's
making me love you more
that's my problem but i know you believe
in god i said
that's not a problem why don't you keep
believing in me and loving me
i'll keep believing in god and loving
god and we'll keep having this great
experience
after i said that he just grabbed me
and he hugged me and he held me
and i knew somehow he was holding on to
possibility that's what i choose to tell
myself
he was holding on to the love that he
could feel for me the palatable
non-judgmental non-persecuting love
and in that moment i couldn't feel more
joy as i held that man
i couldn't feel more joy i i couldn't
feel
more happiness that this is what
ministry is about this
is what touching souls is about is is to
love
the person who thinks that you might not
love them because their belief system it
was just so beautiful
the moment was so beautiful i mean he
held me
and then he drew back and looked at me
and he said you're the real deal
and i looked up at him and i said so are
you
and we said our goodbyes i never saw him
again
margaret and i went up to the room our
hotel room
that night and replaying what happened
we both just started to bawl just
cry and i said to margaret
margaret this is marketplace ministry
[Music]
disguised as a business
i'm not in the converting business i
don't need to convert anybody you're
exactly where you choose to be
but i am in the loving business my job
is to love you where you are
[Music]
and that beautiful gentleman that day
he reminded me and margaret i believe
what unconditional love could feel like
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an action plan for what
you're going to do
you increase it from 35 to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to 95 chance of following
through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below
so i can celebrate you over my career
and i've been in business over 20 years
now
[Music]
people from all around the world
students at every level
whether they are newly into launching
their business
or they've been in business themselves
for 10 15 years
ask the question how do i overcome fear
i'm about to disrupt you completely
because i am not going to give you a
strategy to overcome
fear because if i even attempt to give
you a stress and i know we're always
looking at stuff reading things how to
overcome fears they're probably 10 steps
to overcoming fear somewhere out there
they weren't written by me and i could
never write it because
i don't think you wait to
overcome fear to live the life of your
dreams or the one that you deserve or to
blow your own mind
i personally and i'm teaching you from
my
life lessons from what i've studied what
i've applied what i've implemented
what i've fallen from what i've soared
from what i've gotten up from
and i don't think you focus on
learning how to overcome fear though
there are things that helps to mitigate
your fear
information mitigates fear training and
developing your skill set mitigates fear
i teach speaking
i love teaching people how to speak
powerfully not to speak to be great but
to speak to be unforgettable
whether you're a speaker or whether
you're a manager whether you're in
retails or in network marketing whatever
it is when you open your mouth you won't
be unforgettable
and people always say lisa how do i
overcome the fear of speaking i say
let's not focus
on the fear of speaking because energy
grows
where energy goes so let's not focus on
overcoming fear
let's focus on building a muscle that
naturally dissolves fear and that muscle
is the muscle of information
the muscle of education and the muscle
of skill set
so if you know more and then you develop
the skill set you won't be as afraid to
do that thing
that you're talking about but the other
side to that now i'm going to disrupt
you a bit
so the first part not so disruptive that
means go get more information
give fear what fear needs to to to
reduce itself meaning
information skill set but this other
part that i'm going to tell you
this might be disruptive how about
you not try to mitigate
resolve or get past or overcome whatever
you want to call
how about you not try to do that with
fear how about
you allow to fear to sit with you you
just commit to keep moving
even with the fear so many times in my
life
and in my career i was afraid
the difference between me and most is
that i
still move forward with the fear fear
does not have a pass to stop you
fear does not have a pass to stop you
first of all let me just tell you this
just like compassion just like love
just like respect just like any other
feeling you feel for someone fear is
just a feeling
we just give fear more power we say
when compassion comes i hug i love when
understanding comes
when joy comes when humor comes i laugh
but when fear comes i get to stop
what if you change the meaning to that
oh just
just stick with me right here what if
you change your dance with fear
what if you tell fear you're welcome in
my life because you're gonna come
can't keep your way but when you come
i'm not going to stop if you want some
awesome motivation from tony robbins
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there let me tell you this we said to
have an extraordinary life you got to
have an extraordinary psychology right
extraordinary psychology means you got
to live in an extraordinary state
to be an extraordinary state you got to
condition your nervous system your body
your physiology and focus